et je tweet c'est parti salut tout le
monde
merci d'être avec nous en se Cho moi de
juillet pour ce live
et cette émission vous pouvez vous
pourrez réécouter etc puisqu'on la
mettra sur sur nos plateformes bilan de
la draft au programme et un petit mot de
summerling bon on sait ce que vaut la
sueur ligue on sait qu'il ne faut pas
trop en tirer de conséquences mais c'est
toujours bien d'en dire un mot et c'est
toujours bien de regarder ce qui s'y
fait surtout quand on s'intéresse aux
prospect donc début de perspective et le
bilan de cette draft NBA 2023 qui fut
est bien fort riche nos invités alors je
commence par le local de l'étape je
commence par Mathias membres de la team
envergure comment vas-tu Mathias ça va
super salut tout le monde salut Alex
salut Petite France salut Bastien
salut en vacances le Mathias donc autant
dire qu'il a pu vivre également la
victoire de nos U20
qui était fort agréable avec un avec du
clutch etc donc si vous n'avez pas pu
voir ça c'est toujours dispo sur les
chaînes Youtube de la FIBA autre enfin
non invité numéro
je le prends de gauche à droite tu m'en
veux pas Bastien c'est Titouan qui est
là
du café crème sport
et d'autres
médias je ne suis pas tu peux faire ta
pub si ton instant promo après c'est
fini on parle prospect salut Alex salut
Mathias et Bastien merci déjà Alex pour
pour l'invitation et donc en effet café
crème sport et aussi le trèfle podcast
un podcast spécialisé sur les Celtics
donc tout le monde n'aime pas mais voilà
les Celtics qui ont fait une draft
pas si mémorable que ça mais une draft
quand même intéressante
dernière invité Bastien Trachet j'espère
que les gens vont bien j'espère que vous
allez bien où vous soyez qu'il fait pas
trop chaud là vous êtes
et bien on espère aussi je sais que tu
es armé en terme de d'hydratation tu as
tout ce qu'il faut pour durer et pour
nous parler et donc toi non plus tu
prends jamais de vacances en fait non
de basketball oui non ça fait plaisir on
prend des vacances plus tard là il y a
plein de choses à devoir décortiquer et
puis bon on est à cette semaine dans
mondiale 12 mois de jeux olympiques
donc je suis sûr le déroulement et
l'encadrement sera absolument parfait
et vous pouvez remarquer au niveau de
sourire la gênance de l'approche de
parle de lui-même 4 mais on va rigoler
on va parler de basketball c'est ça
c'est ça on va pas parler de fédération
aujourd'hui mais bien d'une association
et de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
je vous ai demandé en premier de choisir
votre ah oui il y a peut-être Alan qui
va passer il a l'aéroport
il se la raconte il y a le melon vous
pourrez insulter et on dit coucou à tout
le monde je dis coucou à tout le monde
et vous aussi 17 ou à ceux qui sont dans
le chat vous pouvez poser des questions
sur la Summer League j'en ai noté deux
trois on va pas répondre à tout parce
qu'on peut jamais mais au maximum promis
donc les Français ont commencé quand
même par les Français je vous l'avais
pas mis dans le menu messieurs mais
parce que c'était évident
on avait beaucoup de Français dans cette
Summer League on va pas parler tout le
monde on va parler surtout de ceux qui
peuvent soit qui viennent de se faire
drafter soit qui peuvent avoir une sorte
de place dans un roster la dernière news
qui est tombée c'est que Moussa a chopé
un toutouet avec les Clippers
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de de
ces pères de ces derniers mois on peut
parler de on peut parler on peut
englober aussi cette saison vous l'a
peut-être vu je sais pas si tu l'as vu
Mathias ou si toi si vous l'avez vu
jouer
angélique ou pas aussi
qui ça dit
non pas vu beaucoup cette saison
angélique il a eu quelques minutes en
NBA qui était en vrai des passages
plutôt intéressant je pense que les
Clippers s'y croire en Lui sinon il
aurait pas signé pour un deuxième tour
de saison d'affilée je pense qu'il a il
a un truc à faire chez ses Clippers là
qui ont plus ont pas une raquette royale
donc c'est cool faut qu'il continue à se
développer un gilet et qui profite de 5
minutes dans voilà donc il a il a pas
joué à ma connaissance on se met en
ligue j'ai pas trop un petit peu de
garder les Clippers
athlétique comme on aime bien Spino post
et rebond offensif si je dis pas de
conneries je prends un 10 10 il a quasi
un double double je crois je crois que
c'est le premier match
et bah il est bondissant et comme comme
on en parlait à l'instant c'est vrai que
il y a pas non plus la conclus du siècle
à l'intérieur donc chez les Clippers
s'il peut se faire une place
absolument ça peut être intéressant pour
pour le Moussa diabète et Titouan tu as
un truc à dire sur sur Moussa alors
c'est vrai que je l'ai pas je l'ai pas
beaucoup vu en summerlip parce que j'ai
pas beaucoup regardé
mais c'est un joueur que moi que enfin
j'étais
ultra fan à Michigan et et en fait
j'adore le profil bouge bien d'intérieur
qui peut switcher c'est toujours un
Trigon pour pour des front office NBA
donc ouais non je suis pas étonné qui
qu'il est un deuxième contrat je suis
plus étonné qu'il n'est que un touet par
rapport à
la projection qu'on peut se faire du du
profil après on sait que c'est encore
très brut notamment offensivement donc
voilà mais c'est bien qu'il est une
deuxième chance et puis il y a un truc
quand même c'est que les équipes ont un
troisième touet
et ça va libérer des places aussi alors
tout est on appelle un parapluie les
règles parce que je les ai pas en tête
exactement mais il y a un certain nombre
de jours que tu peux jouer chez les
grands et le reste tu vas te développer
tranquillement donc ça permet aussi à la
NBA de se dire ça nous assure de la
présence de joueurs un peu solide en
jillig qui est censé devenir une
compétition de plus en plus de plus en
plus solide pour voir émerger des
talents parfois tardifs
sur les autres Français qui ont été
draftés il y a le numéro 1
moi ça moi ça m'intéresse pas d'en
parler mais si vous avez quelque chose à
dire je vous en prie mais moi ça
m'intéresse pas je considère que la
présence de Victor web benyama à la
Summer League était du marketing et que
ça
n'apporte rien vu l'état de forme qu'il
avait après ça saison etc mais il
fallait qu'il soit là mais peut-être que
vous n'êtes pas d'accord
bon j'en passe juste une en speed moi je
suis d'accord que c'était pas non plus
mais qui a débarqué avec deux matchs à
jouer donc c'était pas non plus
extraordinaire mais
c'est difficile de demander mieux comme
réaction en Match 2 lorsque un mec fait
un match 1 ou il tire la langue au bout
de 4 allers-retours on l'a vu là on a
l'impression que il avait plus de
booster de cet accélère sur une villa
avec les deux gâchettes et le mec avait
plus de boost et il arrête pas de
galérer
avec l'affaire Britney Spears avant avec
plein de trucs etc
c'est pas qu'on le prend pour Hakim mais
je connais très très peu de joueurs qui
pourraient réagir comme il a réagi à 19
piges après ce qui lui arrivait dans la
gueule en 48 heures je trouvais ça très
fort
on sait que c'est il y a de l'orgueil
dès qu'il faut être là il est là
donc effectivement c'était un deuxième
match intéressant on peut parler de
l'autre français des sports par contre
et après on parlera en règle générale
des Spurs puisque c'est le but de cette
de ce podcast et de cette émission c'est
de faire le bilan de la draft mais c'est
d'ici Soco et là ça m'intéresse en fait
de savoir ce que vous en avez pensé
Mathias je commence par toi est-ce que
tu as
déjà est-ce que tu étais déçu le soir de
la draft et est-ce que tu as vu
par séquence on se met en ligue un
joueur qui pouvait peut-être se gratter
une petite place qui part au soleil
ouais forcément j'étais déçu de le voir
drafté aussi bas étonné aussi
là sur cette Summer League il a il a pas
fait une production incroyable il a été
à satisfait mais de toute façon c'est de
la sueur ligue et puis Sidi il a les
qualités maintenant il a les qualités
pour pour et l'expérience pour aller
pour aller chercher un contrat là il
faut potentiellement il a pas encore
signé de contrat je crois pas en tout
cas
je crois qu'il a signé un petit avec les
Spurs le je vais confirmer ça mais je
crois qu'il a signé début juillet un
tout petit avec l'expérience
un tout petit
un espèce de semi garantie je sais pas
mais je crois je vais vérifier mais je
crois qu'il est un truc tout début
juillet mais vas-y je t'en prie
ouais ouais
il y a plein de gens en fait le truc
c'est que on a beaucoup parlé de Sidi et
en fait il y a plein de gens qui l'ont
pas beaucoup vu jouer quoi parce que la
diliggs pas un truc qui se regarde
beaucoup encore moins la
ignight
et lui avait en plus pas le premier rôle
d'un jelly geeknight il était avec scoot
underson
il avait pas le premier rôle il était
dans la hiérarchie quand même derrière
scout évidemment et puis derrière
Leonard Miller il avait un rôle où on
lui demandait pas de d'être la première
option on n'était pas forcément de
mettre des paniers on les demandait de
défendre il a il a le physique il a les
capacité athlétiques pour pour pouvoir
défendre un haut niveau sur plusieurs
positions
maintenant je pense que ce qui a fait
peut-être un peu peur c'est c'est son
shoot son shoot extérieur il finit la
saison à
30%. bon c'est la question maintenant il
est dans un environnement
un bon environnement on le sait chez les
Spurs il a son pote wembi avec lui
maintenant faut qu'il taffe
un contrat garanti avec l'espérance
ça va ça va être public garantie c'est
pas mal
tiens Bastien qui est ce que tu penses
des opportunités qu'il pourrait avoir on
l'a vu moi ce que j'ai aimé rapidos dans
cette Summer League de ce que j'ai vu de
lui c'est qu'on le faisait jouer un peu
dans le rôle qu'il avait Angelique
c'est-à-dire tu as le droit de temps en
temps de d'aller prendre de la
transition parce qu'en transition il est
extraordinaire
mais le reste du temps tu vas faire du
main à main tu vas poser des écrans avec
ton espèce de grandes épaules et du coup
tu vas être un joueur de complément pour
le moment ça ton rôle est-ce que est-ce
que Bastien tu penses qu'il peut avoir
des opportunités hors garbage time
alors autant sur la seule en ligue ça
lui va pas mal parce que vous le savez
comme moi c'est un espèce de grand plus
grand nacelle enfin si elle fermait
si tu as des grosses qui a été
athlétiques et tu as un bon moteur
généralement ça peut très très bien se
passer pour toi
là avec les Spurs il a un mindset
défensive d'entrée que j'aime bien comme
a dit Mathias là
on va voir les histoires de shoot il y a
eu un soir de Summer League où il était
à deux sur deux donc tout de suite les
fans
2016 désormais effectif
on va avoir quels sont les opportunités
mais je pense que il va falloir passer
connais bien par de la chilling et que
s'il a et que s'il a en tout cas un
contrat garanti comme ça se confirme là
il l'aura du Garbes Einstein mais sinon
ils diront bon bah on va essayer de leur
envoyer je pense que ça va prendre du
temps parce que
parce que c'est plus dans des équipes
fortes ou tu as un profil défensif que
tu peux te faire un nom et quand tu es
un profil défensif dans une équipe de
merde très très vite tu dises pas
combien de victoires supplémentaires
l'année prochaine pour les personnes
mais quelle question
dis toi
l'intéressant c'est que moi je vois pas
trop de profil similaire entre
guillemets allez keldon Johnson mais
plus enfin qu'elle donne Johnson est
plus athlétique et plus en place
offensivement évidemment mais
dans le roster des Spurs il y a pas non
plus
il y a pas 20 000 liés quoi il y a
beaucoup d'arrière encore
ils ont aussi
mais non c'est vrai qu'en terme de j'ai
pas l'impression qu'il y ait énormément
de concurrence après faut faire
attention à pas tomber dans le dans le
truc ce que ce que faisait ok ici tout
au début d'avoir 50
000 jeunes et que ce soit la cour de
récré et que au final tout le monde se
développe mais personne se développe en
fait donc ça peut être un peu le revers
de la médaille après c'est 10 ou quoi
vous l'avez dit c'est c'est minute il
les aura en défense
après on sait quand NBA tu achètes tes
minutes en défense mais tu les gardes
avec le tir aussi donc
si si t'as pas de tir au bout d'un
moment ça devient quand même
problématique l'avantage qu'il a
contrairement à d'autres prospects qu'on
attire qui tombe dans d'autres équipes
c'est que lui il va avoir un intérieur
qui stretch ce qui est pas le cas de
tous les intérieurs à NBA et on sait
quand une bière avoir deux joueurs qui
shootent pas sur le terrain en même
temps c'est très compliqué
donc voilà mais moi je suis moins enjoué
que vous peut-être moi j'y crois un peu
moins non pas que j'y crois pas aux
joueurs en fait j'ai peur que ce soit un
des un de ce genre de prospect qui a
besoin de l'opportunité en fait et s'il
l'a pas il peut faire une moins bonne
carrière ou tomber vite dans l'oubli par
rapport à d'autres prospects qui sont
peut-être moins talentueux ou moins de
potentiel mais qui auront eu qui seront
au bons au bon endroit au bon moment oui
il y a toujours cette histoire de oui
du bon endroit après effectivement il y
a eu un peu de recrutement d'expérience
entre guillemets sur les ailes quand
même au sport mais
je pense qu'il va jouer 4 enfin il peut
jouer 4 et il peut jouer porteur de base
pas trop jouer 3 on temporise le
patchoul
cette année il a pris des mauvais tirs
angélique parce que parfois il avait des
ballons à la con mais je crois que sur
la deuxième moitié de saison en cas de
chaîne shoot il est à 37%
. c'est bien 37% avec une vraie ligne à
la vraie distance pas comme les gars en
NCA on change de français
voilà
rien de Rupert drafté juste avant ou
juste après je sais plus
par les Blazers donc qui à côté de ça on
le verra plus tard quand même fait une
très très bonne grâce
alors la bonne nouvelle pour air à
Rennes rupère on est tous d'accord pour
dire qu'il est pas prêt on le savait
c'est que les Blazers ont désormais leur
équipe de jillig
les rips City
je sais plus ce que c'est
pas mal
donc qu'est-ce que vous en avez pensé
sur cette semaine League déjà
compliqué moi j'ai pas mal regardé le
blazer puisque c'est mon équipe mais
compliqué maintenant on le savait et
Anne Rupert sont son gros focus à avoir
c'est
c'est son jeu offensif
on sait que c'est un bon défenseur on
sait que ça sera un bon défenseur même
même en NBA il a tout les qualités pour
ça maintenant la même même de ce côté là
du terrain c'était compliqué en Summer
League c'est la semaine en ligue je me
rassurais en me disant ça à chaque fois
mais c'est vrai que côté offensif il va
devoir trouver son rôle il va devoir
comme Sidi tu as fait son shoot trouver
sa place je pense qu'il aura il aura le
temps de toute façon il a signé un
contrat ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
trois ans je crois de plus simple
donc voilà il aura le temps avec les
Blazers qui sont dans une a priori ni
reconstruction on sait pas trop
donc voilà si on va un peu plus finement
que je offensif Titouan qu'est-ce qu'on
peut
qu'est-ce qu'on peut espérer de Ryan
Rupert parce qu'il y a le shoot mais par
rapport à Sidi il y a encore d'autres
choses sur lesquelles il est en retard
je parle d'appréhension du contact par
exemple mais tu as peut-être d'autres
choses
alors déjà sur le shoot moi il y a
quelque chose qui va mais qui m'avait
vraiment marqué quand je la Réunion NBA
cette année c'est qu'il y a vraiment un
shoot avant sa blessure au poignet et un
shoot après sa blessure au poignet et sa
mécanique de tir est passé du tout au
tout autant avant les pourcentages
n'étaient pas là mais la mécanique était
bonne et depuis sa blessure on sent
qu'il y a comme une fragilité non
seulement sur le poignet mais du coup il
désaxe complètement ses appuis pour
shooter donc on sent qu'il y a une
fragilité là-dessus après au-delà du
foot on l'a vu faire pas mal de
répétitions notamment vraiment belle en
main sur des drives sur des pick and
roll
et il y a encore ouais comme tu l'as dit
de je trouve très
timide dans sa façon d'attaquer le
cercle je sais pas si c'est un blocage
mental aussi il a juste pas les
capacités physiques pour
on l'a vu claquer quand même quelques
dunks je pense pas que ce soit quelqu'un
qui soit sous athlétique mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a un gros problème là-dessus et
vu qu'il a pas ce shoot pour être ce
joueur on va dire se finisseur of Bowl
dans les corners par exemple ou sur du
shoot extérieur
s'il est pas capable de finir près du
cercle avec ou sans ballon ça risque de
vraiment lui compliquer la tâche tu
parlais justement de Sissoko qui est
excellent en transition
c'est pas le cas de Ryan Rupert donc si
tu as pas ce côté là ça limite encore
plus son jeu offensif et son potentiel
d'utilisation en NBA
keep Bastien un mot sur Ryan qu'est-ce
que tu as
Ryan c'était dur que le sort de la draft
sans vouloir être méchant on est sur une
ambiance Green Room avec Rennes Ruppert
donc
[Musique]
tout a été très bien dit
j'essaie juste de voir des garçons qui
ont été soit pas de rareté soit drafté
très bas et qui ont réussi à travailler
alors qu'à la base c'était pas non plus
de technicien horaire type on le disait
bien parfois il me fait penser sous
certains aspects du calibre Martine des
mecs qui sont arrivés en NBA qui avaient
des bonnes dimensions mais pas non plus
des techniciens à faire mais qu'elle est
Martine est un athlète sur par rapport à
par rapport à Rennes donc oui il y a
plein de commentateurs là qui ont vu
rien sur le terrain et qui ont fait
waouh il y a des bras plus quoi savoir
en faire il y a de la défense etc mais
on a vu des Français récemment être
appréciés pour leur mindset leur
potentiel défensif mais pas aller très
très loin suivez mon regard donc
à voir
la meilleure nouvelle pour rien upert ça
a été la demande de trade de damélie
Land
je pense que pour avoir potentiellement
plus de temps de jeu et prendre le temps
de se développer mais c'est vrai que en
l'état en fait à une répartie serait
fort si le basket se jouait comme le
monde avec des changements attaque
défense
oui alors après sur le physique là où on
peut tempérer encore une fois c'est de
dire par exemple si on compare à Sidi
Sissoko il a il était angélique cette
année il a profité des infrastructures
et des programmes de musculation qu'on a
aux États-Unis à une repère était
en Australie enfin en Nouvelle-Zélande
et en plus c'est blessé donc je pense
que physiquement il n'a pour le coup il
a il pourrait avoir un peu un
développement à la
un peu similaire à celui qu'on les bigs
les grands qui ont tendance à atteindre
alors tout le monde atteint son pic plus
vers entre 24 et 28 que avant mais
généralement chez les grands c'est
encore plus tard peut-être que rien ne
Rupert n'a vérifie il est où bordel bah
ça va
on a le temps
et puis il jouait pas mais voilà Ryan
Rupert pourrait prendre un petit peu
plus de temps
[Musique]
au niveau des Français
de qui vous voulez parler désormais
les messieurs
programme il y a pas beaucoup d'autres
Français que j'ai vu en Summer League en
tout cas
moi j'ai vu un peu de Bilal Coulibaly
forcément ouais voilà on peut parler
quand même
évidemment
drafté drafté très haut en 7 de mémoire
si j'ai pas de bêtises Washington
gravité par l'épaisseur des échanger
Washington
non bah Bilal Coulibaly de toute façon
on savait que c'était un prospect
ultra intrigant de par son physique
alors moi je le suis que depuis que ça
aille peut arriver j'avoue que je le
regardais pas avant donc je vais pas
faire genre oui je le sais depuis deux
ans que c'est un jour
c'était pas beaucoup dans son fan club
moi je les avais dans mon équipe mais
c'était les fans clubs Bilal Coulibaly
deux trois quoi
il se tapait dans les mains et tout mais
du coup par contre c'est vrai qu'il
enfin c'est fou ce qu'il est capable de
se faire quand tu vois son physique tu
penses pas qu'il est aussi athlétique il
est aussi solide défensivement après moi
mon seul point d'interrogation sur Bilal
ça va être l'échantillon en fait on l'a
vu finir en boulette canon sa saison
engine ok même plus la Jupiler
Betclic voilà
mais
mais oui voilà c'est c'est un
échantillon de 3 à 4 mois
est-ce que c'était est-ce qu'il était
juste en surrégime ou est-ce qu'il est
capable de répéter ça au niveau on en
parlait par rapport à Ryan Rupert lui
aussi à l'avantage de tomber dans une
équipe qui en reconstruction
et il va avoir un peu de ballon en main
donc ça va être ça va être intéressant à
voir
absolument gros playmaking
défensif qu'il a montré notre notre
Bilal pendant cette cette Summer League
Bastien que tu l'aimes tu l'aimes
d'amour sur l'historique Bilal j'ai eu
la chance de pouvoir le voir
lors du magnifique AX tour l'année
dernière de passage à Paris lorsqu'il
affronté brownie et Brice James
et Bilal était le MVP de la rencontre et
de très loin le meilleur joueur sur le
parquet
alors c'est un match de mois d'août où
sa trottine mais c'était un espèce
d'événement avec des All-Stars jeunes de
côté
US face à des All Stars sélectionnés
côté comme sport et
il n'a pas encore selon moi du tout le
handle pour essayer de se faire une
vraie place offensive en NBA là c'est du
tout droit en semi en ligue et ça lui va
très bien vraiment dès qu'on essaie de
poser des
dribbles et des prises d'écran ça peut
vite être un peu aléatoire
par contre il a l'Allemagne 7 c'est à
dire que
moi je l'ai bien vu justement lorsqu'on
a commencé à parler de lui après cette
histoire avec brownie Bry James quand
j'avais vu jouer et il prend
personnellement il dit c'est maintenant
qu'il faut monter dans le wagon sinon
les portes seront fermées et c'est c'est
il a ce truc là il a ce truc de pas très
gentil qui veut casser des gueules et ça
c'est ce qui me donne confiance c'est
que il a envie de vraiment casser des
bouches et donc derrière bah si tu es
comme ça défensivement et que tu as un
bout de potentiel
il va falloir prendre le temps mais dans
dans quatre ans trois quatre ans je
pense que ça peut être un joueur on va
faire genre waouh ok en fait comment
on met qui à la place en équipe de
France en fait sur les
ben en fait il va prendre du GAB en plus
Bilal parce qu'il a pas fini là ça se
voit quand tu regardes son corps c'est
si toi qui disait ça t'as pas
l'impression qu'il est aussi athlétique
donc il est déjà athlétique impactant
athlétiquement
alors on se met en ligue mais quand même
face à des beaux athlètes
il va prendre du gabarit ouais il va
prendre du Haendel tout le monde dit
tous les témoignages qu'on avait que
vous que vous avez entendu sur envergure
que vous avez pu lire ailleurs aussi
disait ce gars est une éponge
quand il s'agit d'apprendre à
l'entraînement etc il arrive il apprend
il comprend vite il reproduit voilà il a
un cerveau qui fonctionne comme ça
Mathias qu'est-ce qu'il faut lui faire
faire l'année prochaine en fait est-ce
que est-ce que on fout le temps on dit
Jordan pool calme-toi calme-toi bien on
va donner les ballons à Bilal
faut le temps que je pense pas parce que
les Wizards vont vouloir réviser le
titre avec vous les écoute-moi mais
je pense que
il va trouver son rôle il va trouver son
rôle naturellement moi c'est ce que
j'aime bien avec lui c'est que il force
pas les choses il laisse le ballon il
laisse le ballon arriver tout
naturellement
va falloir qu'il démontre encore son
potentiel défensif qui qui soit régulier
tout simplement je pense pas qu'il va
tout de suite une première ou deuxième
option de son équipe ça c'est sûr mais
qui prennent petit à petit les
responsabilités il va les avoir on va
lui donner je pense parce que les
Withers crois en lui c'est pas pour rien
qu'il a été drafté en 7
maintenant quelques réserves quand même
parce que 7 ça c'est très très haut il
manque cette petite qualité élite chez
Bilal mais mais comme le disait Bastien
moi j'adore son mindset il dégage une
sérénité une confiance en lui une
détermination qui me font être vraiment
optimiste avec lui et il a que il a que
18 ans il aura 19 dans quelques jours
mais petite taille note d'ailleurs c'est
nouveau manage à Washington qu'il a pris
donc eux croit en lui par contre il y a
toujours le père western sell de Junior
qui est en place donc j'espère qu'il a
profité de la capitale parce que dans
huit mois c'est un nouveau coach et ils
le font responsabiliser parce que lui il
va nous mettre des nièces devant et des
Johnny Davis et compagnie donc à mon
avis les vont dire doucement quoi après
Bilal l'avantage je crois qu'il a déjà
montré que jouer à côté enfin dans
l'ombre d'un ou deux joueurs je crois
qui je crois qu'il sait faire oui et
puis de toute façon il y a jamais une
seule star une fin très rarement
des systèmes à Star unique dans les
franchise quand même merci Guillaume le
basket Lab pour une fabule le jeu de
mots que j'ai affiché et ce sera le
dernier
allez on passe on passe à vos à vos
notes on a si vous avez d'autres
questions sur les Français dans le chat
moi je prends mais on va pas parler que
des Français on va refaire la draft et
qui qui qui a fait la meilleure draft
selon vous en terme de franchise et là
je mets tout de suite Titouan
sur sur la question comme ça tu as pas
besoin de choisir ton ton choix bis
du coup j'en ai pris trois au cas où
j'ai choisi le Yuta jazz avec donc
Taylor Hendricks et breathen sabot
donc
Tyler Hendricks est choisi en numéro 10
8 9
j'y suis quinté de georgence 16 et
Bryson sabot en 28 pourquoi tu trouves
que c'est une bonne
alors je trouve la valeur du profil
Hendrix dans la NBA actuelle c'est à
dire de la rime protection et du foot je
trouve que c'est un profil qui a pas mal
de valeurs et sa fille pas mal avec
Kessler
derrière tu as un pic qui d'ailleurs
paradoxalement a pour moi et pour moi un
pic plus potentiel que celui d'Hendrix
c'est OK George que j'adore alors je
serais peut-être pas objectif sur lui
mais qui est un fort chocmaker qui peut
défendre et en fait il a montré qu'il
pouvait faire pas mal de choses
notamment le triptyque donc dribbler
passer shooté et du coup je trouve qu'il
y a une certaine multitude de
possibilités de développement avec lui
il est encore un peu brut offensivement
notamment dans son plume making il perd
pas mal de ballons mais en fait en
fonction de ce que le coaching staff va
vouloir faire de lui tu peux vraiment
faire tu peux vraiment l'orienter dans
diverses pistes de développement
différente que ce soit du en faire un
shotmaker un tout à player parce qu'ils
défend plutôt bien à un Bolender
créateur enfin il y a plusieurs
possibilités avec lui je trouve ça très
intéressant et derrière à la fin tu as
un pic que j'ai appelé un peu classique
le risque i reward donc très peu risqué
mais qui peut payer je suis pas le plus
grand fan de Brice sent sabot il y a pas
mal de gros interrogations sur sa
mobilité sa capacité à
être négatif aussi
et ça reste sa capacité à pas être
négative défensivement
mais c'est un beau shooter un gros
scorer donc en fin de premier tour je
trouve que c'est un pari qui peut se
tenter pour une équipe comme le jazz
donc voilà
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire le jazz
l'année prochaine là avec ces joueurs
Bastien il veut me Kissi ils vont faire
l'année prochaine c'est quoi le projet
j'en vois que certains réagissent
notamment dans le dans le chat c'est
vrai que j'aime beaucoup comme des
citrons la draft du jazz ils ont ils ont
un truc très intéressant c'est un
management agressif un excellent coach
en formation où il leur dit qu'on avait
vu d'ailleurs s'occuper des gamins de de
Summer League avec les Spurs à
l'ancienne et qui est en train de faire
sa main il est passé après quoi Boston
udoka et maintenant il est à Yuta en
place qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire bah il
y a du monde qui barre Hendrix donc moi
je me demande ce qui va se passer parce
que Daniel je sais le mec le point
prévisible du monde à la direction donc
il nous a prêté mais en même temps dans
la même semaine il nous a pris John
Collins il y a quand même du monde à
l'intérieur donc moi ce que je pense
c'est Kyota en tout cas pour répondre à
ta question ils sont sur un projet
excitant jeune où il garde quelques
pièces pour les transférer par la suite
on vient de voir Clarkson prolonger
pareil Jordan Clarkson s'il peut passer
six mois avec qui on était de genre j'ai
eu dire voici deux trois tricks à
rajouter dans ton dans ton dans ton
Arsenal ça peut être très bien mais
attention Yuta ça peut être le genre
d'équipe ou en fait on se retourne dans
deux trois ans et on est là genre c'est
qui vraiment qui a le meilleur Yang
corps parmi eux et eux donc ça va être
une équipe qui va essayer de gratouiller
le le play-in mais il se gêneront pas
s'il faut reposer du monde en fin de
saison et encore gratter du Bic bah
ouais mais du coup Taylor Hendrix quoi
il va il va pas beaucoup jouer quoi
Kelly olini chlory marcannen Walker
Kessler enfin voilà après ma question
Mathias c'est est-ce qu'il peut jouer
trois pour toi
non parce qu'en fait il a le tire il y a
pas de problème
est-ce qu'il peut 8 sans doute mais ce
qui doit je pense pas ce serait dommage
de passer à côté de ces qualités de
protection d'arceau tout simplement
c'est c'est
offensivement
et faire du du roaming défensif ouais
mais même même ça dommage de ne pas
l'avoir à l'intérieur de la raquette
parce que c'est un bon finisseur un gros
gros finisseur en trois ça me paraît
ça me paraît
que les casques
pas d'avoir une rotation à trois Hendrix
Kessler et Collins avec évidemment
Hendrix qui dans un premier temps aura
le moins de temps de jeu parce que bah
il est jeune et encore à développer un
peu
effectivement donc est-ce que vous avez
et donc qu'est-ce que vous pensez au
fait de la draft deuta Mathias et
Bastien je vous ai pas posé la question
c'est la préférée de Titouan
préféré aussi
le drap le jazz ils ont drafté les 8 9
et 10 de mon board donc
je peux difficilement trouver une draft
pas mal réussi non mais Brice and sabot
c'est le pic parfait en 28 comme disait
comme des Titouan c'est le risque i
reward le meilleur attaquant ainsi il y
a de la draft pour moi à côté
meilleur donc ouais à voir sa défense of
ball parce que pas loin d'être
catastrophique mais si ces genoux
laissent tranquille
on va entendre parler de Bryson Savo
Ie
je répète qu'il a glissé notamment à
cause de
d'inquiétude sur ces genoux sortis genre
un jour ou deux avant prévu son point
kilos enfin voilà je veux
non je disais il y a toujours une équipe
comme ça qui profite des chutes de draft
qui flirt comme ça et qui prend même qui
ont été il était annoncé parfois c'est
descendu en 12 13 à un moment et il
finit à Yuta tranquille c'est une sabot
on en parlait en quoi 16-18 il finit en
28 bon bah il y a des franchises comme
ça qui parfois se ramènent et disent
bon bah ça marche très bien mais ce qui
est marrant c'est que de notre point de
vue de notre œil on voit des espèces de
case libre et ils ont pris exactement
les joueurs qu'il fallait je crois que
tout le monde a vu la draft du jazz et
s'est dit c'est c'est très très
fort donc je ne peux que valider et
alors notre cliente est déjà qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que tu en as pensé pendant
la Summer League pour moi c'était quand
même le c'était une belle surprise parce
que je sais que c'est un fort joueur il
y a pas de problème j'ai regardé les
matchs mais là il a quand même été pas
loin d'être le meilleur Rocky sur la
Summer League ce qui est quand même
solide solide solide
sur lui c'est tu sens que il y a un gars
de ce groupe là quand on faisait le live
de la draft et vous aussi j'imagine
quand vous avez toute cette liste de
gardes là qui sont tombés là les Hawkins
les Antony black machin il y a un gars
qui peuvent qui n'est compagnie il y a
un gars qui va sortir de Solo qui va
être le meilleur ça peut être qui
intelligent mais
il va falloir juste voir si c'est ce
type de profil de Uta a besoin
sur le long terme parce que c'est une
gâchette et il y a du monde à nourrir
donc moi j'aime bien le profil je sais
juste pas si sur la durée ça a été que
ça se passera
le truc c'est qu'il a montré un petit
peu plus que une gâchette et qu'il a
surtout été efficace qui était un peu
Titouan pour revenir sur son année un
peu ces deux plus gros défauts quand
même c'est à dire clairement et que ce
soit au scoring mais aussi mais aussi
aux playmaking au playmaking il y avait
pas mal de flash où il crée à bailer
même s'il avait pas énormément d'usé
j'ai pas le taux d'usé j'ai sous les
yeux mais
ce qui a été intéressant c'est qu'en
Summer League il l'a fait en perdant peu
de ballon chose que qui n'était pas trop
le cas à la fac parce qu'à la fin qui
perdait pas mal de ballons quand il
était dans des dans des phases de
création pour les autres après voilà
comme tu l'as dit depuis le début on le
rappelle mais ça reste la summerling
mais pour moi c'est un peu le swing
skills comme on dit c'est sa capacité à
pouvoir créer pour les autres tout en
gardant de l'efficacité si c'est le cas
alors tu peux avoir un joueur très
important dans ton effectif très
intéressant si c'est pas le cas dans ce
cas tu vas être bah typiquement sur un
profil à la Jordan Clarkson en fait qui
va être plus sur du sur du scoring pur
et pas grand chose d'autre autour
de nous donner ton choix qui selon toi
quel franchise a fait la meilleure draft
vu que tu t'es fait piquer du tajas et
je voudrais pas que tu te fasses piquer
tout plomber
non mais c'est pas la seule équipe avoir
fait une belle draft alors vas-y si on
nous avait dit avant la draft que que
les roquettes qui selon les rumeurs et
les insiders hésité pour le pick 4 entre
amen et 8 morts finalement repartir avec
les deux sans avoir aucun trail
d'affaires donc je pense qu'on serait
pas grand monde à y croire donc
draft réussi amen en 4 même si je suis
pas son plus grand fan arrivé dans une
équipe avec un manque criant de
playmaking ça tombe bien c'est son plus
gros point fort à côté à côté de ses
qualités athlétiques évidemment même si
l'arrivée de vente a peut-être limiter
un peu plus son statut prévu mais en
tout cas c'est le joueur idéal pour les
besoins des roquettes en ce moment et
puis à côté bah la draft passe et puis
on pique 20 BIM kamout mort qui a glissé
pour des raisons un peu floues on sait
pas trop entre le dossier médical et
les Intel qui se serait mal passé donc
tu ressors avec de la draft avec deux
gros potentiels qui étaient annoncé top
10 à peu près tout au long de la saison
et puis si les deux peuvent s'apprendre
quelques trucs genre amen qui apprend à
calme faire des passes et Cam qui
apprend à la main à mettre un 3 points
ce serait ce serait cool donc ouais même
si c'est deux joueurs avec des gros
points d'interrogation sur certains
domaines de jeux importants NBA ça reste
une draft très réussie pour moi
c'est vrai
déjà déjà
Bastien
wit more qui glisse
vous aussi pendant votre Live vous étiez
un peu vous saviez pas pourquoi une
Mathias dit on sait pas trop pourquoi
moi j'ai l'impression quand même que
c'est pour le physique
mais très mal passé apparemment les
interviews ouais mais ça se passe jamais
aussi mal
ou alors c'est vraiment qui est débile
mais vraiment tu rates pas
[Rires]
il y a un potentiel après le talent vous
l'avez connu beaucoup plus tôt que moi
je j'imagine moi je me refaisais c'est
quoi avec les US où il déchire tout
c'est U19 ou U20
quasiment 40 points enfin c'est le
meilleur score de Team USA sur la
compétition si je dis pas de conneries
MVP ouais
c'est un bulldozer il va se correr etc
mais il y a des il y a des gemmes qui
voient ça et qui se disent attends
est-ce qu'on peut compter sur lui dans
le vestiaire est-ce qu'on peut compter
sur lui pour faire des passes est-ce
qu'on peut compter sur lui en défense il
y en a qui évaluent plus ou moins les
interrogations et disent c'est sur voir
du scoring mais les œillères elles sont
comme ça quoi je veux dire il va faire 4
passes décisives d'ici 2025 et dans une
belle année quoi donc
talons offensif incroyable scoring
mais je pense qu'il y a des franchises
qui se disent je sais pas par exemple
vous est-ce que si vous êtes une
franchise qui est en construction et qui
se dit tiens j'ai besoin de quelque
chose sur les ailes est-ce que dans une
aire on a besoin de trendy et de gars
qui sont capables de se faire sortir en
fait dans un quatrième carte de match de
playoff est-ce que tu prends le cambouit
More ou est-ce que tu prends certains
gars là je sais pas du milieu de tableau
des des reméjacaises ou des getters
par exemple
du talent vous allez me dire de Camille
est mort mais demain matin comme kam
Johnson il fait un quatrième quart de
playoff
intéressant comme point de vue Titouan
est-ce que tu étais d'accord moi j'ai vu
des choses sur cette Summer League
défensivement qui était relativement
pas pire par rapport à ce que pouvait
produire qu'à monitement en termes de
compréhension de l'attaque adverse en
NCA là ça ça pouvait aller parfois aller
en fait je trouve ce qui est bizarre
dans sa chute c'est que même si oui il
est prêt au scoring mais dans tout le
reste il y a encore beaucoup à faire et
on sait un de ces gros soucis c'est ce
qu'on va appeler le
QI basket et que c'est un des points les
plus durs à travailler c'est pas comme
le shoot où tu peux juste faire des
gammes et progresser
en fait ce qui est ce que je trouve très
étonnant et quick Morse c'est que
dans pas mal de compartiments comme vous
l'avez dit par exemple la défense il a
les outils athlétiques et physiques pour
être un bon défenseur après on sait que
avoir les outils c'est une chose
à côté il faut avoir la compréhension la
lecture des défenses
évidemment les efforts et tout ça et du
coup je suis étonné qui fut aussi bas
qui est pas une équipe
dans le top 15 qui s'est dit ok pour
l'instant il est pas prêt mais avec les
outils physiques qu'il a si nous on
arrive à le faire cliquer ça peut être
un carnage donc
pour moi je pense vraiment que dans les
entretiens il y a le côté physique
blessure j'entends potentiel et je pense
qu'il y a vraiment un problème je peux
dire psychologique mais dans la tête
quoi on va dire que ça il doit y avoir
un petit souci un truc qui tourne pas
rond parce que comme tu l'as dit Alex tu
chutes pas de 15 places par rapport à ta
projection une quinzaine de places juste
parce que tu as stressé à un entretien
non
donc c'est que ça doit être un peu plus
dark que ça je pense non alors je peux
dans le chat Aurélien dit qu'il a un
covid long
entendu parler moi non plus
et je trouverais ça
en fait je trouve que c'est une théorie
qui a du sens si c'est le cas mais j'ai
jamais lu ça sur kamut donc
je te vois faire la moue Bastien non
plus donc
probablement qu'on ne fera jamais
en tout cas s'attendre à ça sauf si il
devient une star et dans ce cas sera à
belle histoire en fait il avait eu un os
supplémentaire dans le genou
pour rebondir sur ce que disait Mathias
par contre ouais c'est un truc de ouf
j'imagine même pas la gueule de la
waruma Houston quand on leur a dit
on peut finir la soirée
pendant 4 semaines à savoir si c'était
pingoupong et ils font ping pong la même
soirée enfin c'était là genre bon c'est
une belle draft c'est une belle draft
par contre j'aimerais bien j'aimerais
bien te au training camp de Houston pour
assister à un concours de dunk contre
Jane green en même temps sonne et
Camille more je pense que il y a moyen
de s'amuser et à le Perrine
est arizon surtout et arizon
ouais il y a du il y a du Jump mais
alors qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de tout
ça
Bastien tu dis belle draft oui c'est
vrai
il y a pas de doute sur le les deux
potentiels maintenant est-ce qu'ils
avaient enfin il fait quelle taille le
staff de développement personnel des
Houston Rocket parce que là il y a du
monde il y a quand même du monde à faire
taffer
ils ont déjà fait du déménagement tu as
été Washington et
Ousman garroba ça va te dire un an et
demi c'est déjà on sait même plus et
c'était c'était là donc il y a du
changement de de direction il y a du
changement de coaching staff merci ça
hélas merci toute la clique John Lucas
et tout donc maintenant c'est dans les
mains diminue de cas et on va voir ce
que ça donne il faut une hiérarchie il
faut une culture il faut une culture et
une hiérarchie moi si on me demande des
demain et je veux bien vos avis à vous
trois
en voilà un copain qui est passé par sa
Merlin Smith on a vu un peu les
développements demain c'est la franchise
de qui le Jalen green de jabarit Smith
tu veux faire un axe quoi aventum
sunjavary Smith ou challenge green Kamui
more bon il va falloir mettre une
hiérarchie ils ont pris des vétérans
pour entourer tout ça c'est bien
bordélique ça va pas je crois pas que ça
va aller chercher le play-in mais ils
vont s'amuser comme Utah et chercher les
places sans à 15 mais je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez vous sur la hiérarchie à
Houston c'est c'est quoi les dans quel
ordre vous mettez les trois meilleurs
joueurs autour desquels construire bah
si tu me demandes de faire une draft des
pas des vétérans mais du coup mais des
draftés je mets toujours du challengrine
en un et j'ai pas de question
oui
moi j'ai en fait j'ai tout j'aime pas
utiliser le mot sur côté mais je trouve
que jabbary Smith était
projeté beaucoup plus fort qu'il l'est
enfin je pense que ça va être un joueur
très fort mais pas aussi incroyable et
polyvalent que ce qu'on peut le projeter
et amène Thompson je suis loin d'être un
grand fan de lui moi c'est ça tenait
qu'à moi j'aurais fait qu'un mouilles
morts à main Thompson avec les roquettes
mais dans le sens inverse j'aurais pris
amène à maintenant
vous êtes pas chaud
moi je suis chaud moi
j'exagère évidemment mais en fait j'ai
vraiment ce ce que beaucoup créé
d'ailleurs mais je veux voir la
transition
overtime NBA là déjà enfin juste sur
c'était intéressant de le voir sur la
semer League d'ailleurs je sais pas si
vous avez regardé les matchs de Houston
mathiason déjà direct
défensivement alors il a toujours des
trous il est chiant il joue
l'interception et tout sauf que il est
quand même vachement en place
tout le monde était là ouais ça va être
dur de jouer un pick and roll et tout il
est en place il est il a du under il va
au Cercle enfin voilà quoi
en plus bon après il a fait que un seul
match en ce moment-là tout le monde
disait oui mais l'opposition
[Musique]
au premier match et à on a vu que pas de
problème pour lui de défendre sur scout
et ça l'empêchait pas non plus de
montrer autre chose de l'autre côté du
terrain
[Musique]
la tête en faisant non après en faisant
oui je sais pas ce que tu penses d'amène
Thomson
qui a envie qu'on parle de comme
d'autres de Albert n5oon
moi ce que j'aime ce que j'aime bien
c'est que oui l'étiquette est un peu
facile enfin un peu facile à coller elle
est évidente à coller overtime c'est
dégueulasse à regarder le shoot il y a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de travail
mais qu'est-ce qu'ils ont l'air malin
les deux frérots là qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
l'air intelligent beaucoup plus que ce
que je pensais quand j'ai commencé à
fouiner un peu j'étais là genre attends
en fait c'est des vrais cracks du jeu
qui aiment bien analyser dans tous les
sens qui ont envie de travailler dur qui
se challenge
bon ils ont le shoot c'est une chose
mais ils ont la finition c'est à dire
que quand tu peux faire des fingerho le
main droite main gauche par dessus des
pivots pour moi ça me donne le sentiment
que tu peux travailler ton tiers c'est
pas elle frite Payton ou c'est le bordel
absolu et on va essayer de voir ce qu'on
peut essayer de dénicher sur la durée je
pense vraiment qu'ils peuvent s'en
sortir et puis ils font partie des
0,2 % des meilleurs athlètes de la
planète donc je pense que hamment
Thompson sont planché est super
pour peu que le shoot se développe un
peu on a vu plus de deux trois cracks et
15 dernières années qui sont des
athlètes de fou furieux qui ont le shoot
et après tout s'ouvre
et pour en revenir à 5 goon et à ta
question initiale moi je suis très
partisan d'un challengreen 5 good et tu
construis autour et c'est jeune qui
viennent d'arriver jabary Smith amène
Thompson si parce que c'est comme ça qui
sont vraiment au dessus en fait ça va
revenir le jeu va venir vers eux parce
qu'on va voir qu'ils sont plus efficaces
etc et du coup bah tu vas changer ta
hiérarchie c'est pas grave mais pour
l'instant la hiérarchie c'est celle là
et amène Thomson on va lui demander
d'être efficace sur le sur le porteur
adverse de pas faire trop le coin en
défense de distribuer d'apprendre des
choses de frais de vente blitt et même
si je suis jamais à 40% ou même à 35 pas
extrêmement grave faut que je chute au
moins 30 pour pouvoir jouer en playoff
quoi
mais et jabarit Smith il a été excellent
et il commence à savoir dribbler et tout
donc c'est intéressant quand même et
faire des passes surtout
donc ça paraît les bases mais c'est il
savait pas faire il était pic numéro 3
et c'était compliqué quand même
Bastien quel est ton choix pour la
meilleure draft
j'ai pas pris Houston donc on est bon
mais bon sur la prépa
je voulais donner un peu de Love à nos
amis les Mavericks
c'était mon plan B ah ouais carrément
ouais
je crois qu'on a nous avons fait un
podcast aussi un lien en sortie de draft
l'année dernière
je crois que c'était il y a un an on
faisait un
retour un peu sur la droite
j'aime beaucoup les franchises qui
annoncent qu'elles sont leurs priorité
et qui font des draft pertinentes Nico
Harrison il arrive il y a quelques temps
on a un peu transpiré là avec les
histoires de Karine et le 46 il a dit ok
il a fait son choix avec Dorian Smith ou
la laisser partir pour kerving il a dit
je veux des qualités athlétiques au
poste de pivot et de la protection
d'arceau et je veux un mec sur les ailes
qui peut défendre sur plusieurs postes
et ensuite on va voir si le potentiel
offensif se développe
et au max Maxence prospère donc du coup
je ne dis pas du tout que ces deux gars
ou un de ces deux gars va devenir un
multiple star pas du tout mais une
franchise qui travaille bien c'est une
franchise qui s'est ciblée qu'elles sont
ces problèmes et qui peut avoir une
timeline de 2 à 3 ans pour voir si ça
peut donner si ça se trouve Derrick en 2
ans c'est le pivot titulaire des maths
ou dans trois ans ou en tout cas qui a
un super backup et qui arrive à faire
une longue carrière il va avoir une
activité de fou furieux des sa saison ok
je vous laisserai mieux en parler que
moi sur sa saison à Duke mais je crois
que voilà je pense à un meilleur
plancher quand même que Jackson un peu
dans ce genre de voltigeur de mec qui
aime bien faire du volley-ball je
préfère moitié perso sur son plancher et
un bout de chou en plus à développer et
puis Olivier Maxence Prosper
les minutes tu les achètes en défense
mais tu les conserves aussi aux shoots
la défense je pense qu'on va pouvoir la
voir et après s'il y a un peu de
pénétration un peu de muscles et un peu
de shoot bah tu l'as peut-être là ton
bras infinix donc je sais pas j'ai
beaucoup apprécié ce qu'ils ont fait
avec en plus mais c'est pas la draft
mais c'est toute leur summeries
Jane Hardy qui a montré des très très
belles choses là en Summer League alors
que c'est plutôt
scoring scoring et pas trop playmaking
et là ça se voit il y a déjà en coach il
lui a dit on va te filer les clés tu vas
essayer de faire tourner toute cette
belle machine j'aime pas trop parfois
donner des éloges hommages mais là je
trouve que c'est du très bon travail et
je me demande ce que vous en pensez un
peu tout good to play Summer League
Jaden Hardy maintenant ça commence à
bien faire il jouera pas l'année
prochaine quoi
c'est parti de cette équipe là Mathias
Titouan les
un peu moins c'était du coup comme j'ai
dit c'était mon plan B aussi globalement
pour les mêmes raisons que que Bastien
je trouve qu'ils ont essentiellement
c'est vrai piqué au fit comme on dit
mais s'il y a bien une équipe en loterie
qui pouvait se permettre de le faire
c'est bien Dallas forcément
parce que Louka tout simplement et je
vais faire une petite parenthèse très
courte sur les finances NBA mais en gros
avec le nouveau cibier il va être de
plus en plus difficile de monter des
effectifs avec beaucoup de gros contrats
donc en fait je pense qu'il sur le moyen
court terme même il va être primordial
de bien drafter même en dehors du Top 10
du top 15 pour maximiser les contrats
Rocky et en fait obtenir un rendement le
plus intéressant possible entre la
valeur terrain du joueur et ça va leur
contrat donc contrat Rocky qui est assez
faible et je trouve que c'est ce qu'on
fait les maps avec Lively même si Lively
a un peu de du travail à faire mais je
trouve que c'était un des meilleurs
pivots et un des meilleurs rimes
protecteurs de de
il y en avait pas beaucoup aussi donc ça
aide et je trouve que bah pareil au max
c'est un c'est un évier fort défensif
comme l'a dit Bastien qui qui va pouvoir
se rôles un peu de délier polyvalent
avec un petit upside offensif je pense
que les maps vont viser là-dessus en
fait on dire il va pouvoir nous apporter
quelques minutes en défense et on va le
faire travailler offensivement pour
qu'en fait ils viennent c'est un peu le
raccourci facile mais qui deviennent un
peu le swendy que tu veux autour de d'un
gars comme Lucas ou comme Kairi mais
qu'est-ce qui lui manque Mathias pour
jouer pour avoir des vrais minutes
l'année prochaine
à dire à Dorian Smith
au max
va falloir qui qui développe un petit
peu son jeu sans ballon pas rester un
poids mort côté offensif pour son équipe
c'est ça son principal
axe de travail je pense
améliorer aussi son shoot il a un petit
peu quand même déjà il le fait
progresser très doucement chaque année
mais ça progresse mais ouais moi j'aime
beaucoup ce choix des masses il y avait
un renne à la drave de d'équipe
compétitif là le Miami Warriors Kings
spacer aussi je crois et finalement
c'est les maps qui avait même pas de
choix draft qui qui finalement sont
montés pour lui moi je trouve ça très
intelligent un joueur qui va qui aura
des minutes on suit persuadé que les
fans des maps vont adorer
vont adorer par son activité défensive
mais c'est sûr que offensivement va
falloir ne pas être un handicap pour une
équipe
c'est pardon
c'est très particulier d'avoir
dans son équipe je pense donc il faut
des joueurs avec des personnalités et
des capacités de jeu qui fit avec ça des
profils qui filent défensivement
offensivement mais faut aussi accepter
le fait d'avoir
un peu d'ombre un peu de retrait et de
faire le sale boulot et
franchement c'est quoi ça doit être
poils aujourd'hui la concurrence avec ma
guide de Derrick Lively
dans un an et demi hormis c'est réglé
donc à lui de bien se développer mais
pour au max c'est pareil
maxicleber il est toujours là oui et
parfois il utilise plus en 4 pour
essayer de stretch mais vraiment
de soucis de
drogue et de sèche mais
d'ailleurs ça fait partie
mais juste sa petite parenthèse
là-dessus pour moi ça fait partie de la
bonne réussite de la draft des mobs
parce que ça fait partie du package
draft c'est d'avoir dumper le salaire de
Bertens tout en
tradeback donc en reculant la draft de
deux places parce qu'ils étaient au pic
10 et quand même récupéré le joueur qui
voulait très fort très fort donc je vais
totalement dit-on
c'est solide Dallas ils ont pas
énormément de marge et ils ont fait
exactement ce qu'il fallait
on passe à la suite
on avait Dallas on a parlé de Dallas
est-ce que vous avez d'autres choses à
dire sur Dallas ils ont pris quoi
ils ont pris
ils ont pris ils ont pris je regarde les
undrafted free agent parce que
ils ont pris
porter
ils ont pris Mike miles ils prennent que
des croqueurs quoi
Mike miles rapidos
Titouan ou Matthias ça ressemble à quoi
champion avec Team USA face à Victor
un peu petit mais très bon shotmaker
très bon
playmaker joueur qui ressemble un petit
peu ton profil à Marcus à sa sœur qui
était drafté par les pistons moins moins
intéressant
défensivement mais c'est ce profil de
jour là
provoque beaucoup de fautes tout le
temps c'est un peu la constante dans son
jeu c'est beaucoup de fautes ensuite
allez c'est le moment
j'ai pas envie de faire le coup de
gueule tout de suite
le meilleur site le joueur vous est dit
bah tiens
ça ça tombe bien quand même c'est pas
mal pour lui pour la franchise pour tout
le monde évidemment vous n'avez pas le
droit de citer des équipes qui ont déjà
été citées c'est la règle du jeu et
c'est cette fois Bastien qui commence
puisqu'il est en dernier coup d'avant
comme je dis avec Dallas une équipe qui
grave ce bien c'est une équipe qui sait
reconnaître ses faiblesses et qui a une
vision court et long terme
j'ass Walker Indiana j'ai dit allez
merci c'est bon ah je vois que ça
soupire très bien
voilà rien que nous déjà là on est
d'accord donc en fait ils ont des
galères des tout va bien en attaque il y
aura pas de problème avec ils ont un
trou béant en défense ils ont besoin
d'un mec hyper athlétique hyper défensif
qui adore ça qui peut apporter un tout
petit peu en attaque parce qu'il y a un
bout d'attaque quand avec Jas mais qui a
un mindset absolument merveilleux je
l'avais vu d'ailleurs jouer avec Darry
Quest de George je crois qu'ils avaient
fait ils avaient fait AMG je sais plus
ce qu'ils avaient fait comme comme
cursus quasi similaire il y a un match
notamment avec darkoated qu'on peut
retrouver sur Youtube contre je crois
que c'est Walker et qui ont été George
je vérifie mais c'est
c'est le feat ils avaient besoin sur ce
poste de Forward un peu quatre un peu
trois qui va adorer avoir les meilleures
attaquants adverses il l'a montré là on
Summer League il a envie tout de suite
de faire des dingueries et il a du il a
de la vision du jeu donc franchement je
te laisse enchaîner là dessus Mathias
mais pour moi il y a il y a un monde
dans lequel on lui accroche des posters
de dream on green dans son vestiaire et
on lui dit tiens vas-y
tout à l'heure on parlait de très bonne
Grinch et puis je sais plus Rocky et
j'avais envie de dire c'est les pays
c'est l'épaisseur ce qu'ils vont drafter
très moderne
jazz Walker il va faire une raquette
avec My sterner assez assez
impressionnante défensivement et puis
c'est un joueur qui a pas que ça à son
arsenal il s'est passé le ballon
il s'est scoré quand même il a un shoot
qui a progressé d'une manière assez
phénoménale entre le High School et le
NCI je vous invite à aller voir des des
sa mécaniques en High School c'est assez
drôle
mais ouais là le site feat à Indiana qui
en plus avait un post-4 assez vacant pas
profond
ça semble parfait ça semble parfait pour
eux on a tous fait comme ça en fait je
me rappelle bien parce que c'est
Coulibaly qui a annoncé donc on fait
tous
comme ça faire bon
Coulibaly numéro 7 alors on est content
numéro 7
et puis quand même j'étais là moi
j'étais sur le plateau de la forcing
mais vous étiez sur d'autres plateaux
moi j'ai très rapidement dit ça sent le
trade quand même enfin c'est pas
possible quoi ça sent le trade
effectivement
trade avec avec les Wizards bien joué de
la part des Pacers conçu faire levier de
l'intérêt qui avait grandi sans et de la
hype Bilal Coulibaly pour aller
gratouiller deux petits tours de draft
alors c'est des second tour mais ça vaut
des sous
Wizards contre contre la
montée pour aller choper Bilal et eux
ils prennent déjà un smoker bon bah
voilà tout comme tu disais Bastien tout
le monde était là bon bah c'est évident
et puis ça se passe bien quoi c'est
comme c'est comme une belle histoire
d'amour quoi tout le monde est là autour
voilà c'est beau quoi c'est beau tu peux
rien dire c'est un peu chiant presque tu
vois parce que moi je le voyais jouer le
premier match je disais mais il est
dominant il y a une vitesse une
réactivité latérale une anticipation
dans le côté faible qui est à cet âge là
quasi jamais vu pour pour ma part c'est
très très très fort j'ai rasp Walker
Titouan en t'as pas entendu là-dessus
un bon retour globalement je suis
d'accord avec vous moi ce qui m'enchante
c'est le secteur intérieur d'épaisseur
cela le trio un peu Turner Walker et
Isaia Jackson défensivement tu as trois
profils différents tu peux vraiment te
mettre les schémas que tu veux je trouve
ça je trouve ça ça peut donner des
choses vraiment incroyables donc ouais
Walker défensivement son énergie son
seul
sa polyvalence et en plus il a montré
des progrès offensivement donc j'ai du
mal à voir ce genre de joueur ne pas
réussir à NBA en plus dans dans un
environnement comme l'épaisseur c'était
pas sous le feu des projecteurs de New
York ou de choses comme ça donc il y a
pas de raison que ça se passe mal
j'ai une petite question juste pardon
Alex
je me permets de vous poser une question
qui est pas mal de débats pendant la
draft sur Jas Walker vs taylorhendrix
vous aurez réagi comment citer leur
Hendrix il a été Indiana
ça aurait été un bon fit mais c'est pas
la c'est pas du tout le même genre de
joueur
pour moi taylorhendrix c'est pas un
joueur qui est prêt à apporter
année 1 et donc c'est un joueur qui va
demander un peu d'amour en tout cas
[Musique]
même si défensivement il est plus dur
que que ce qu'il est offensivement mais
je
pense que j'aurais réagi bizarrement
parce que moi j'avais déjà rasp Walker
je plus 5e ou 6e sur mon bord et Mathias
je crois que c'était pareil on était
tous on était tous super chaud et Lauren
drix c'est à part à part du tir et à
moins de flash d'autres choses et puis
surtout il y a moins de flash de cette
extrême intelligent
qu'on voit qui transpire de jaraz Walker
à chaque moment où il est sur Internet
basket puis c'est un point que quand on
regarde moins quand tu choisis dans le
top 10 et la draft mais je trouve que
Hendrix défensivement un profil un peu
plus semblable à Isaia Jackson
que j'arra swalker que je trouve plus
plus défenseur plus plus au sol on va
dire même si c'est un monstre athlétique
qui peut sauter mais
je trouve que tu peux faire peut-être
plus de schémas offensifs différents
quand tu as une doublette Walker Jackson
Walker Turner que si tu as Hendrix qui
est du coup plus dans la rime protection
un peu plus classique si je peux le dire
comme ça
Mathias si tu voulais tu voulais ajouter
un truc non non si ce n'est peut-être
charlest Walker il a quand même pris 10
kilos en un an là entre sa saison
Bryson sabot aussi
a pris beaucoup de poids là en un an on
le voyait dunker sur n'importe qui en
High School là on a un peu perdu ça même
si
ils sont peut-être souvent avec des
petits flotteurs assez insupportables
parce qu'on sait qu'il est capable mais
c'est vrai qu'il a pris beaucoup de
poids en un an donc
c'est plus c'est plus les tomates et
Alan qui sont qui sont là dessus donc
j'y connais rien mais effectivement
avoir c'est disponible sur les sur les
internets tout à fait
donc Jarry Walker et Indiana évidemment
l'évidence bien joué bien joué Bastien
fallait le prendre fallait vite le
prendre avant qu'il soit plus désolé
Mathias allez cette fois cette fois
c'est pour toi je te laisse ton numéro 2
du coup je vais partir sur un jour du
second tour je vais partir sur short and
Wolf
hoston a perdu
Marcus Smart
Williams qui d'autre que Jordan walk
franchement pour représenter
cette passion de la défense
sur Dan walk c'est au très compliqué
Arkansas un contexte horrible aucun
spaceing un ballon enfin il avait pas le
ballon quoi le ballon était était pour
Nyx Miss quand il jouait ou alors il
était pour Ricky Council voir voir Davis
donc très compliqué pour lui de se
montrer offensivement et même ta
financement là où c'était censé être son
point son point fort parce qu'il est
capable de switch sur n'importe quel
joueur n'importe quel poste et ben même
là il a été compliqué parce que
il vous laisse montrer il vous laisse
montrer absolument comme c'était
compliqué un attaque il a voulu se
montrer en défense et trop d'intensité
trop de fautes qui ont limité ces
minutes et là on l'a vu à une Sommer
League complètement libérée en confiance
le ballon beaucoup plus dans les mains
et on a retrouvé un peu le Jordan walk
de Live School avec un shoot
qui peut à terme fiable et puis quelques
flashs de playmaking donc Jordan walk il
va rien dans une équité celtique qui a
besoin de défense je pense que il peut
clairement avoir des minutes de sa
première année
d'ailleurs il a signé un contrat si je
me trompe pas c'est même pas un Touré il
a signé un contrat sur un poste trois
quatre je pense qu'il peut il peut avoir
un rôle à jouer à Boston
alors on va demander à notre bostonien
d'ici là d'abord une question
la draft qu'est-ce que tu en as pensé
c'était impossible à suivre la draft de
bretonne en direct
alors
le bilan global que je me suis fait
chier à résumer dans un autre notre
trade bilan de la draft c'est que à la
base tu as un choix fin de premier tour
et tu finis avec un choix début de
seconde tour
plus plein de futurs second tour en gros
et tu transformes le pic 25 alors
j'espère je vais pas dire de bêtises je
transforme le pic 25 en un pic 38 + 4
futurs secondes tour de draft si j'ai
pas de bêtises c'était ma conclusion
aussi ouais
donc non non oui moi j'étais très
content parce que je pense que n'importe
quelle fan veut toujours que un de ses
chouchous de la cuvée tombent dans son
équipe et quand tu draft au second tour
bah tu dis que la probabilité que tu
tombes sur ton chouchou et quand même
assez très limité
donc non j'étais très content après
Mathias on a parlé longuement je peux en
rajouter surtout que c'était pas mon
choix pour le meilleur feat mais je l'ai
choisi pour une autre section du live
donc j'en parlerai peut-être un peu plus
tard plus longuement
mais je rejoins je rejoins Mathias sur
le côté où il va pouvoir potentiellement
avoir des minutes dès sa première année
même si je pense que offensivement il y
a encore pas mal de rouleau c'est
surtout parce qu'il va bénéficier du
fait que ta grande Williams qui est
parti et que sur les ailes il y a pas
derrière derrière Tatum sur les post-3-4
et pour zinkis maintenant il y a pas de
remplaçant où tu dis ah il va forcément
enfin il est forcément largement au
dessus j'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup
ça mother que que j'adore depuis qui
était mon drafté mais enfin depuis où
est-ce qu'il jouait j'ai perdu ça tant
pis à Virginia oui
mais
oui non je pense qu'il a pas énormément
de concurrence on va dire sur les
minutes sur les ailes donc je répète
étonné qu'il ait quelques minutes en
saison régulière du moins et c'est un
joueur qui sait tout faire enfin on vous
l'a assez vendu c'est le seul joueur du
second tour je crois qu'un avec un
Ruppert qu'un podcast consacré un
portrait prédraft consacré chez nous
envergure parce que ça fare
effectivement et Mathias l'a très bien
dit donc juste rapidement
on n'avait pas j'ai pas fait j'en ai pas
profité pour faire le bilan de la draft
d'Indiana
à part Jared Walker on a drafté quand
même ben Shepherd en fin de premier tour
et on adrafe tes
King et Isaia Wong au second tour
est-ce que vous avez
des
choses merci bodile pour les services
rendus c'est bon on a la suite
crise du
étonnant parce qu'ils ont drafté haut
enfin
loterie
vu la gâchette moi je souhaite la même
car que Basile parce que l'autre en
dessous de sa gueule de Deal c'est quand
même un autre livre
s'il faut un copain dans les corners ou
qui prend des écrans j'ai l'impression
de mettre je sais pas pour le faire donc
j'ai une Diana
drave des seniors c'était celui de cette
année voilà
ça fait même plus que ça j'ai
l'impression
mais ouais bon rafting moraf je peux
bien le dire à mexicaine quoi
mais je sais pas ce que si vous avez une
opinion sur Mojave King monsieur mais
moi je le voyais jouer angélique
j'aimais pas
j'avais pas j'ai pas regardé mais je
l'avais regardé à l'époque en NBA il est
en NBA il y a deux ans je crois si j'ai
pas de bêtises
et je voyais des trucs intéressants je
le trouvais assez similaire d'ailleurs à
un autre Français qui était en NBA à
l'époque c'était Ousmane Diagne
et oui oui plus petit mais dans ce
physique un peu filiforme et bollender
et en fait j'étais IP sur deux trois
matchs de pré saison de NBA et en fait
après sur le long de la saison ça
tombait en décadence plus ça allait plus
tu voyais les défauts grossir grossir et
tu voyais aucune progression
donc maintenant je je pense que lui et
il yaoung de Miami ça va faire des
petites pigeons Jelling mais attends les
deux il faut les deux alors surtout ils
ayent il va se régaler au Fenerbahçe
dans deux ou trois ans quoi franchement
mais moi j'avais King il fallait être
stage de toute façon je crois si j'avais
bien vu ah ok j'avais pas cette info
dealer avec Francky Ferrari une autre
légende de ah oui ah oui
Ferrari c'est un excellent
absolument name team
et bah dis-toi on t'a piqué tous tes
choix ou non du tout du tout moi je suis
parti sur un feat beaucoup plus un choix
beaucoup plus facile parce que je pense
que en fait ce genre de profil il fit
avec n'importe quelle équipe c'est great
diddick au Raptors
alors comme je l'ai dit un choix facile
puisque un shooter un shooter comme ça
élite tu peux je pense qu'il y a aucune
équipe qui dit non
je pense que c'est un si ce n'est pour
moi le meilleur shooter de la CUV et
contrairement à certains j'ai vu pas mal
de comparaisons avec comparaison facile
avec des Duncan Robinson par exemple je
trouve bien plus athlétique et capable
de faire plus de choses offensivement
que juste du shoot même si tu as une
canne Robinson c'est élite aussi dans
son shoot et je pense que s'il y a bien
une équipe qui avait besoin de spacing
c'est bien les Raptors donc donc ouais
j'aime bien le feat j'aurais peut-être
voulu qu'il prenne un peu plus de talent
qu'ils aillent chercher un peu plus un
joueur avec un plus gros obside
notamment sur le bac courte mais mais le
feat en tout cas vu qu'on parle que du
feat pour moi le le fit est très bon il
aura des minutes dès sa première année
et je serai pas étonné qui qui les
exploitent très très bien
Bastien sur gridi
et scottybound c'est bon
dans le cœur des fans des Raptors il y
aura pas de problème
juste encore un garçon qui avait pas mal
de trucs en High School et parfois la
machine à Sillé peu un peu
cadenassé donc on a vu Christiane Brown
faire son truc du côté de Kansas essayer
de trouver son rôle à Denver pas étonné
pareil si grésil x sortie de Kansas est
nettement plus que lundi Titouan un
simple shooter
c'est un gars qui à la taille et qui a
la polyvalence il a l'air d'avoir le
mindset aussi donc ça va le faire mais
comme ça a été dit
un peu plus de talent je suis surtout en
fait intrigué par ce qui se passe au
global attendant parce qu'il y a plein
de gemmes
quoi on sait pas qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
prévu de faire donc c'est quoi en fait
le jeu c'est toujours sciacam plus
Scotti band plus gris Dick
on verra est-ce que tu vas pas chercher
un plus un plus fort potentiel à ce
moment là
ou alors est-ce que tu penses que c'est
eux ils pensaient que c'est le meilleur
potentiel peut-être là au moins limite
tu peux les comprendre c'est si enfin la
dynamique c'est de donner la balle à ce
côté Barnes et de le laisser faire le
buffle et d'avoir des snipers dans les
dans les recoins là où je veux bien que
ça soit comme ça mais si c'est pour
avoir ce que tu bandes bouché par chacun
après la question c'était le feed pas
est-ce que les Raptors sont viendrater
et pour le coup le fit est mais c'est ce
que je disais c'est que ce profil toute
façon il fit dans n'importe quelle
équipe mais que tu continues accès à cam
ou que tu vas avec ce que tu band tu as
toujours besoin d'un ailier qui shoote
comme ça surtout que c'est pas un
shooter
comme on peut l'entendre spot-up shooter
dans le corner avec les pieds dans le
ciment c'est c'est un shooter un shooter
en mouvement c'est
ultra value et bol je trouve bah on l'a
vu avec d'un cadre winsene en play hop
d'ailleurs
avec Miami je trouve que c'est très
valué ball surtout qu'il est pas négatif
défensivement même si il y a pas mal de
boulot à faire quand même et les Intel
sont très très bons de gready Dick en
tout cas de ce qui leur sort d'un point
de vue mental c'est un gros bosseur
c'est un gars qui ouais qui est très
intelligent donc j'ai aucun souci sur sa
progression NBA je pense niveau
vestimentaire très haut également draft
c'est ça d'ailleurs qui fait chier j'ai
l'impression Alex comme tu disais c'est
que c'est un trait safeak donc ça feat
mais est-ce qu'il y a des gars dans 4-5
ans on fait la draft et on va se dire
pour moi c'est vraiment un choix de
Suisse quoi tu vois
la place de Toronto ils auraient pris de
gridyk
parce que pas dire que c'est mauvais
[Musique]
Mathias est-ce qu'il va pouvoir défendre
great Didi que l'année prochaine moi
c'est ma question sur lui en fait
la question que tout le monde se pose
sur lui après il a des joueurs autour de
lui à Toronto pour pouvoir défendre
n'esquive pas la question comme ça non
mais est-ce qu'il a les outils
ce sera pas son point fort maintenant il
a les c'est un meilleur athlète qu'on
peut le qu'on peut le penser c'est quand
quelqu'un qui qui bouge bien qui qui est
quand même bien développé physiquement
ce sera pas son point fort mais je l'ai
vu quand même plutôt à l'aise dans la
défense sans ballon
plus en difficulté sur des sur des gros
sur des gros poste 3 ça pourrait pas non
plus la rue en NCA mais ça t'intéressant
d'observer ça en NBA mais oui ce sera
pas ce sera pas son son point fort il
peut il peut éventuellement être ciblé
défense plus collectives que sur l'homme
pour grid diddick il y a pas grand chose
d'autre à dire sur la draft des Raptors
qui n'avait pas d'autre choix et qui ont
signé un twei marquis Noël un joueur
très fun mais qui mesure un mètre
16 têtes max quoi
et qu'à frôlé ou qu'il a battu le record
de passe
en marche Madness je sais plus pendant
pendant une rencontre de marshmallet
cette année marquis Noël fun allez le
voir jouer mais Angelique visiblement il
y aura pas trop de minutes avec les avec
les grands
voilà pour pour les meilleurs sites de
cette draft et maintenant
on en a marre
le coup de gueule le coup de gueule le
choix que vous n'avez pas aimé la draft
globale que vous n'avez pas aimé le mec
vous comprenez pas pourquoi il était
drafté aussi haut ou aussi bas ou les
deux
donc qui n'a pas commencé Mathias n'a
pas commencé
je le savais pas j'ai fait des
transitions tout seul
c'est incroyable vas-y parle de Grey
didique tout veut dire quoi non mais
c'est plus de la déception qu'un coup de
gueule parce que une équipe de Toronto
qui a perdu
qui a perdu kylory il y a deux ans ou un
an qui a perdu Fred van beat maintenant
après la draft et au moment de la draft
ils avaient pas grand monde pour pour
être il y a mal accueil
frites
[Musique]
voilà après ils ont arrivé avec un pic
numéro 13 qui ont déjà dispo outils
dispo et puis ils prennent graditique
le choix ultra sage
sans risque pourquoi faire ça je ne je
ne comprends pas ce choix c'est quand
j'ai vu ce pic arrivé
c'est pas compris j'étais persuadé que
Toronto allait prendre un meneur prendre
un peu la relève développer il y avait
des joueurs franchement il y avait des
joueurs c'est ça le plus frustrant c'est
qu'il y avait des joueurs aller chercher
crédity qui va jouer où sur le poste de
qui et c'est Gary train c'est de faire
porter la balle au grand du coup imagine
et l'artiste Scotty quoi c'est ça bon
mais du coup donnons le ballon à Denis
Schroeder
[Musique]
ouais c'est vrai qu'ils ont pas
beaucoup de d'autres porteurs de ballons
bah du coup
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
Bastien est-ce que tu
peux te positionner je me marre désolé
c'est parce que évidemment
et qu'on arrive sur gready Dick dans le
chat au niveau des jeux de mots c'est
parti
la frustration sur le Dick pic est
particulièrement élevé sur ce sur ce sur
ce thème du côté de Mathias ouais moi je
suis je suis d'accord on était on est
dans ce règne il y a plein de garde qui
sont dispo et ça semblait être évident
tu sentais que 28 allait bouger moi je
voyais déjà un outil fino débarquer et
que ça allait être parfait pour eux
ça m'en dit long sur aussi le virage qui
a Toronto ou c'est unique nerf
et on est en train de discuter de voir
si
Masai va rester si longtemps que ça bon
il y a quelque chose qui se trame à
Toronto il y a un nouveau coach et je
sais pas ce qui se passe et je sais pas
qui va rester et du coup bah quand c'est
comme ça chaque Mathias secoue la tête
bah c'est des draft on sait pas ce qui
se passe
merci Alex
bah vas-y vas-y Bastien ou non ou
Titouan
alors moi j'ai choisi Marcus ça sert en
25 à D3 les jeux de mots aussi vraiment
alors bon non seulement je suis pas
spécialement fan de la projection du
joueur NBA qui est mon en a parlé
brièvement quand on a quand on a évoqué
le quart de tissu dont j'ai perdu le
loup mais Marcus ça sert donc c'est un
meneur undersize qui a déjà 22 ans très
peu de Side et je trouve le feat très
limité quand on voit que les pistons
sont déjà quelques lignes gammes Jaden
Ivy Kylian eyes alors eux ils ont le
problème inverse de Toronto c'est qu'ils
ont déjà pas mal de Guard dont certains
avec quand même beaucoup de talents donc
et en plus eux ont des besoins plutôt
sur les ailes et quand on voit que
derrière il y a du Julien strowser call
big Jones qui sont disponibles même
Leonard Miller
je me dis que un de ces noms a été plus
intéressant et la cerise sur le gâteau
de ce pic 25 de Detroit c'est que non
seulement il draft ça sert en 25 mais en
plus ils ont
c'est à dire qu'ils ont lâché des assets
pour faire ce choix donc enfin vraiment
alors il y a toujours la jurisprudence
de l'intersaison et du fait qu'on va
attendre de voir les débuts NBA du
joueur comme toujours c'est le terrain
qui sera juge de paix mais pour être
clairement le choix pour moi est
vraiment pas bon
bah attends il a mis 40 points Summer
League trop fort trop fort c'est tout le
mal que je lui souhaite trop fort
ouais moi j'ai pas aimé non plus quand
j'avais fait que j'ai regardé comme ça
j'ai fait le bien il met un trade up
mais j'aime bien mais alors
bon Bastien Kylian eyes
ou quoi parce que on fait comme si il
était pas là apparemment on avait parlé
d'incertitude à Toronto je sais même pas
envie de parler des trois s'il y a des
pattes de piston mais franchement projet
bancal très weer on en peut plus le soir
ou trois hiver est arrivé sa première
draft vous en souvenez il y a eu cinq
intérieur qui sont tombés dans la même
minute c'était un running gag tout au
long de l'été on savait pas ce qui
allait se passer avec pluie avec OK fort
avec machin on sait pas ce qui se passe
on va voir qui a le ballon dans les
mains
Ivy
kenningham que va-t-il se passer avec
qui Anaïs maintenant il y a mon petit
Williams bon
on va voir mon petit William s'il a eu
raison il a pris le plus gros contrat de
l'histoire des coachs bon après il y a
pop qui a dit je vais prolonger à San
Antonio
mais
non non je suis dit devant là dessus
quand on a vu on sait plus se marrer sur
le nom sa sœur que autre chose et quand
on a vu qu'ils avaient trader on a dit
mais attends c'est
c'est aberrant alors on lui souhaite
tout le enfin moi je souhaite à ma
rédaction de se mettre cartonne parce
que là c'est open bar pour faire des
petites articles mais quand on est là en
sortie de draft à prier pour qu'il
explose grâce à son nom de famille
next allez je vais faire un peu l'avocat
si je regarde le roster de Détroit et si
je veux donner la balle à Kate
Cunningham ce qu'il faut faire
maintenant ça commence à bien aller
on parlera un peu de on en parlait avec
Alan en off Alan qui qui a l'aéroport
peut-être qui va passer
de Jaden IV qui parfois c'est compliqué
si tu donnes la balle à Kate koenigam et
que tu veux jouer avec un autre arrière
le meilleur feat d'un gars qui met
s'étire qui défend fort
c'est pas déjà donné c'est pas qu'il y
en Ace et du coup Marcus sa soeur là a
du sens
je trouve en tout cas c'est
la seule raison que je peux trouver à sa
présence ici parce que après c'est vrai
qu'ils ont beaucoup de ils ont du mal
ils ont monté mon risque
ce qui est mieux que ça sert mais voilà
c'est ça peut ça peut jouer entre
guillemets sur sur des petites rotations
en étant un joueur qui va forcément
fluidifier ton jeu c'est un joueur qui
arrête la balle Marcus sa sœur c'est pas
un croqueur c'est pas Mike miles junior
donc dont on parlait tout à l'heure qui
qui va aller forcément jouer son duel
etc c'est quand même très
quand même assez smooth ça vient du
basketball de la fac de Houston ça s'est
joué il est déjà expérimenté
donc je dis pas que ça vaut un premier
tour mais
disons que
c'est pas le côté de garde ce qui
m'emmerde c'est plus c'est plus le côté
on monte effectivement pour
pour ça est-ce que tu veux défendre avec
moi Marc sa sœur Mathias
je peux essayer moi aussi
en prenant un peu de recul c'est vrai
que Marc sa soeur bon moi j'aime bien
marquer sa sœur c'est un joueur ça fait
trois quatre ans et c'est le leader à
Houston ça fait trois quatre ans que
Houston et une des meilleures équipes de
NCIS
il y a un vrai leadership
et en soit le Move de Detroit de monter
en 25 ans
pourquoi pas c'est pas forcément un
mauvais choix le truc c'est que c'est
pour prendre Marcus ça sert qui était
dispo au deuxième tour quoi
c'est ça qui pose question après
il y a des questions autour de lui c'est
sûr que c'est pas un choix qui qui fait
rêver
excellent coup de gueule Titouan on
était sur d'accord alors là bravo
j'attends c'était un peu le c'était un
peu le jazz Walker des coups de gueule
tu vois tout le monde était un peu
d'accord c'est de faire illusion
à toi Bastien
c'est pas forcément contre un joueur
mais c'est contre une fac oh alors ça
c'est pas c'est pas courant ça tiens
il lui arrive des soucis au pied le
pauvre dark whited donc
on va voir ce que ça va donner
j'adore la gestuelle j'aime bien le
potentiel sauf qu'il y a peut-être sur
les épaules et que j'aime bien le garçon
je vais me refaire l'historique de Duke
depuis 10 ans
j'ai commencé à regarder l'état du
bordel
et je suis attends
la royauté est là depuis des années
parce que on sait qu'il y a des gars
super qui sont arrivés qui ont fait des
grandes choses coach etc
il y a peut-être un moment où il faut
utiliser un coup de gueule pour dire que
sur les 10 dernières années hormis Kairi
Tatum et on l'espère par le banquiero il
y a quoi de safe
quand tu débarques de High School et que
tu finis à Duke il y a quoi de safe
parce que c'est prestigieux comme
université tu y vas c'est carré il y a
des mecs qui font des longues carrière
il y a des mecs qui vont réussir etc
mais juste pour que ce soit enregistré
dans l'histoire et brandingram pardon je
suis méchant il est là juste dans
l'histoire
pas de chance d'avoir eu par coeur pas
de chance Zion pas de chance j'ai eu le
cas fort pas de chance à Eagles pas de
chance qui ensuite Marvin baglet pas de
chanson harpaud à camrydish pas de
chance qui c'est qui le prochain en fait
et j'ai l'impression que dryquoistel
il va rentrer quoi dans cette liste
aussi des mecs qui étaient il est
annoncé quoi dans les boîtes de Top 5
top 3 avant d'arriver à Duke
bon
coup de gueule c'est genre oui pendant
des années on était là Duke nors
Carolina super donc Kentucky est arrivé
a fait merci cordialement mais
aujourd'hui tu es formé à Dieu que bon
enfin non mais c'est pas des franchises
players mais en même temps ils étaient
pas annoncés comme tel
Carter c'est un top 8 de draft dans une
draft 2018 où il y a du sacrément au
moins je souhaite une très belle
carrière je dis pas qu'il y a que des
bosses qui tombent il y a des mecs qui
vont faire des longues carrière mais le
ratio
entre un mec des barres de school fini à
Duke et qu'est-ce qu'il va faire comme
carrière on peut continuer à monter
derrière Austin Rivers
Parker je me demande enfin Zion et
jabarit pas par cœur c'est des gars qui
ont vu leur carrière ruiner par des
blessures je me demande à quel point
le fait enfin l'université dans laquelle
ils sont passés ont un lien en fait avec
ça j'en veux pas à Duke en mode truc je
dis juste si tu as avoir un coup de
gueule c'est est-ce qu'il y a un peu de
chat noir est-ce que les trucs parce
qu'il y a des gars qui ont quand même
des trucs qui leur arrivent en sortie de
Duke c'est c'est pas de la faute de
l'Université des fois qui sont comme ça
Portland on s'est tapé des barres
pendant des décennies parce qu'on a dit
tu es à l'intérieur tu finis importantes
c'est foutu c'est pour ça qu'on croisait
les doigts pour Victor ne finisse pas
mais je suis pas en train de dire que
des mecs finissent là-bas et donc sont
morts c'est juste que quand on prend la
liste de tous les gars soit il y en a un
il est pas au bon endroit soit l'autre
il a pas il a pas été bien encadré sur
l'Odyssée pas bien développé soit lui il
a eu des pommes blessures il y a
toujours un truc et donc sur l'entièreté
des mecs qui sont choisis les dix
dernières années à Dieu
il y a quoi il y a quatre très très très
bon joueur
j'ai beaucoup mais c'est déjà très très
bien je parle de Tatum
en fait ton coup de gueule il est il est
plus sur les ranking près NCA qu'autre
chose parce que on sait pas pour de
récré il va cartonner oui alors pour le
coup lui il a quand même pas eu de
chance avec son corps et ça c'était
difficile après avoir mais les rankings
pré NCA
ils sont fait en fait non les rankings
de draft prêt NCA puisque les ranking
pour pour qui va peser en NCA à la
limite tu vois tu vas plus valoriser des
intérieurs avec d'autres paniers
pourquoi pas mais
en fait c'est vrai avec toutes les facs
qui recrutent des gars qui vont faire du
one and down ce que tu dis
et il y en a même qui vont ensuite pas
se présenter parce que bon ou là ma cote
elle a baissé puis en fait en deuxième
année ou là bah non bah du coup je me
présente pas puis en fait du coup je
fais pas de carrière alors que j'étais
top 10 recrut machin etc on a vu des
comme ça on a vu je suis pas en train de
dire que un parce que je vois qu'il est
sur le chat que par exemple que vous
avez la carte est terminée c'est pas ça
je dis
j'ai vu que c'était réagir ou que pareil
ou que je dis que ça n'a lieu qu'à Duke
c'est pas le cas ça a lieu dans plein de
fac je dis juste ouais le mec et quand
tu demandes à des gens comme par exemple
comme moi qui suis pas aussi expert que
vous sur par exemple du niveau
universitaire il y a des facts qui ont
des standings assez élevés par leur
historique parce qu'ils ont fait etc du
coup pour moi et peut-être que je me
trompe et j'ai besoin de votre update je
faisais partie d'une forme de royauté de
tu y vas tu sais que ça va cartonner
force et de constater que non pour
diverses raisons mais justement en fait
en fait ton coup de gueule c'est plus
sur la vision que les gens ont de Duke
plus que le potentiellement c'est pour
ça que je voulais ouvrir le vraiment
ouvert la page pour avoir votre envie
parce que c'est à ça aussi que ça
l'invitation d'Alex c'est que moi je
suis un peu moins tu vois mais le coup
de gueule c'est
what the fuck with Youk ou est-ce que
c'est un truc qui est isolé ou enfin en
gros moi maintenant ça y est il y a un
truc qui est entré ou je vais me dire le
gars de l'année prochaine qui sort de
Duke du coup c'est c'est qui pas en fait
et jusqu'où il va et est-ce que il faut
tu es un garde qui sort du top 10 tu vas
devenir un pack comme ça avec les terres
et compagnie il y a peut-être un truc
aussi ou en fait je sais pas je l'ai un
peu mauvaise voilà
bon c'est vrai qu'il y a pas mal
d'échecs mais il y a aussi plein de mecs
Guillaume basket Lab dans le chat parler
de Kentucky alors même si tu as eu ces
belles réussit tu as eu aussi plein de
gars qui ont disparu et qui étaient
attendus au top 10 15 c'est
principalement de Kentucky de que je
parlais tout à l'heure mais même cette
année
Mathias on avait encore des gars qui
sont arrivés à Kentucky au final Chris
Livingston il a été drafté ou pas je
sais même pas en dernière position
il était top 15 20 recrut quoi mais
juste qu'il existait pas dans le mais
après je suis d'accord avec ce que dit
Bastien mais
après c'est aussi dû au fait que les
facs comme doux qui sont très près très
très réputés c'est aussi les facs qui
récupèrent beaucoup de prospects et donc
forcément il y a beaucoup plus de
chances d'avoir du buzz là l'année
prochaine je crois que c'est qu'un
tukies ils ont trois prospects au moins
dans le top 5 là cette année c'était Joe
qui en avait trois il y avait des
réclave ITOP 3 taekwight ed top 3 et
quel type les poissons qui restaient
encore une année qui était top 5 donc
forcément ça fait trop de prospects pour
certaines équipes et forcément ça fait
plus de chance de derrière mais c'est
vrai que le prestige qui accordait à
Juke peut être remis en question des
fois mais on sent un glissement en tout
cas moi je sens un glissement voir avec
toi Titouan peut-être
[Musique]
le wandon est en train d'être de plus en
plus
réservé à une élite de plus en plus
restreinte
Mathias parlait à l'instant de kyfield
qui fait une très bonne saison à Duke
qui fait même une meilleure saison plus
exposée que des reclive par exemple mais
juste il lui manque des trucs pour être
choisi assez haut en tout cas ce qu'il
estime assez haut pour aller en NBA du
coup il revient ce qui se faisait pas
trop avant avant tu te présentais je
suis allé à Dieu que je reste un an quoi
tu vois je veux pas rester deux trois
ans à Duke et il revient
et il y a d'autres Yata iris Proctor qui
revient
et ça a commencé du côté Arizona
Benedict naturel revenu et ça a payé
deuxième année etc donc je pense qu'on
est en train de vivre un basculement de
cette fin d'air de one and down et
peut-être il y a Kentucky qui est encore
un petit peu là-dedans mais c'est aussi
une histoire de coach recruteur et
avant c'était sur sa fin de carrière en
tout cas coachka il
pensait plus peut-être à la lumière qui
allait produire du du basket-ball là la
NCA restera
mais il fournisseur mais s'il y a bien
un truc qui m'a marqué en lien avec
histoire de Dieu que le soir de la draft
c'est qu'à un moment on s'est arrêté en
top 7
Bilal 5 des 7 premiers pics ne sont pas
en LCL alors les autres aussi ils sont
et tu parlais d'une potentiel bascule on
va voir aussi des
alternatives qui ont continué à se
développer en entier mais ça restera le
main une provider je pense de talent
juste voilà un élément en plus de
potentiel interrogation tu te dis est-ce
que je vais à Duke ou est-ce que je vais
faire de la night ou du overtime Elite
ou ailleurs où tu fais comme Emmanuel
moudier tu vas tester la Chine quoi
[Musique]
si j'ai pas de bêtises
j'ai aussi il y a même plus un peu plus
ouais Chris dorter
trois quatre ans vraiment
du tremer feed des gars comme ça qui en
fait même deviennent Mitchell au Kings
où j'étais le premier à crier quand ils
l'ont pris en neuf alors que enfin alors
que voilà il y avait des des gars et
peut-être un plus gros upside derrière
et finalement on a vu que ces joueurs
ont eu un impact rapidement en NBA et
alors ta carrière est jamais assurée sur
20 ans mais bon déjà grâce à un bon
début on a assuré quand même sur court
terme leur avenir NBA et je pense qu'il
y a beaucoup de joueurs qui qui doivent
se dire ça se dire bah finalement c'est
plus de temps un problème que ça de
d'entrer en NBA à 22 ou 23 ans et puis
ça rejoint ce que tu disais tout à
l'heure sur le le la valeur qu'on va
donner aussi au contrat Rocky qui qui
pourrait augmenter on veut des joueurs
qui sont prêts voilà on n'est pas là
pour te former en gros toi quoi c'est ça
et quand même la majeure raison à ça et
ça va encore plus glisser dans les
années à venir c'est que maintenant il
gagne leur vie en NCA en plus
[Musique]
c'est plus d'un million je crois qui va
gagner l'année prochaine qu'il aurait je
sais pas où ça en est ce dossier
d'ailleurs dossier à démarrer du côté du
ciel est mais c'est des chiffres
astronomiques les droits les droits à
l'image qui sont négociés par les facs
avec les joueurs c'est truc qui
d'ailleurs sont en train un peu pourrir
la NCIS je je dis
et je l'assume mais
c'est des choses qui font que les
joueurs en tout cas les gros joueurs
certains gros joueurs peuvent rester et
peuvent monétiser et par exemple si on
prend des routines il n'y a pas d'avenir
en NBA au moins c'est cool pour lui
parce qu'il peut faire il peut faire un
peu de flouze pendant qu'il a qu'il a
encore beaucoup de valeur et rester chez
lui parce qu'après il sera sans doute
obligé de s'exporter si puisque c'est un
très bon joueur de basket il y a pas de
problème mais pas pas dans la grande
ligue
mais je suis content parce que le coup
de gueule a généré une discussion plus
large oui bravo effectivement
mais on finit avec Justin Timberlake
sum love
qui était votre coup de coeur de la
Summer League
messieurs et ça va nous permettre de
parler de des équipes qu'on a qu'on n'a
pas évoqué en terme de draft réussi ou
non
très tranquillement je vais essayer des
de rebondir à chaque fois
et ben avec qui qui veut se lance je ne
lance personne
moi je vais commencer parce qu'on en a
déjà parlé du coup on va faire vite et
j'ai pas fait mon humeur jusqu'à
maintenant donc je vais le faire
maintenant
et c'est surtout parce qu'en fait c'est
l'équipe que j'ai le plus vu en Summer
League
moi on en a parlé voilà de son rôle à
arkensa ce qui était assez limité
et la grosse interrogation c'était son
shoot et même si je prends comme on l'a
dit toujours les performances bonne ou
mauvaises de Summer League avec des
pincettes ce qu'il a montré retiré
porteur de grands espoirs
après ce que je trouve intéressant de
regarder en Summer League c'est pas tant
les pourcentages la ligne de stats ou le
résultat final du match ça m'intéresse
pas trop ce qui m'intéresse c'est plus
de voir en fait dans le détail quel type
de jeu le joueur va jouer est-ce que
c'est en adéquation avec ce qu'il va
faire NBA ou est-ce que c'est juste un
joueur qui a carte blanche et du coup va
faire des choses mais tu le verras
jamais en NBA par exemple si Jordan walk
prend la balle drip pendant 10 secondes
et faire un step back à 3 points même
s'il le met ok c'est cool pour lui mais
je m'en fiche parce que c'est pas ça qui
va qui va avoir en NBA et en
l'occurrence pour le shoot sur Jordan
walk je me suis pas mal attardé sur sur
le type de tire prise sur la mécanique
le rythme et cetera plus que les
pourcentages et je trouve qu'il les
prend avec confiance il les prend à
l'aise il est beaucoup plus en rythme et
sa mécanique est bonne donc ouais c'est
tout ça qui que j'ai trouvé très très
encourageant c'est pas le joueur qui a
mis des plus grosses lignes de stats
mais j'ai trouvé ça très très
encourageant par rapport au point
d'interrogation qu'on avait lui au
moment de sa draft on lui a demandé de
prendre du volume je pense les shooters
shoots et là on lui a dit bon bah toi
faut que tu sois un peu shooter quand
même mon Jordan il a shooté il a bien
shooté alors
échantillon très petit qui ne présage de
rien mais c'est des surpris par la
mécanique aussi je t'avoue et par là
quand tu as des bras aussi longs c'est
énorme il parle le côté
décision c'est à dire que je prends le
shoot tiens c'est naturel en fait
ce qui joue beaucoup au basket savent
que c'est pas si facile pour les joueurs
qu'on ne sont pas forcément des shooters
naturels adroit ou maladroit mais juste
d'être dans le réceptionner tout de
suite je suis prêt à tirer
et la fluidité allez Bastien à toi
dans le chat qui ont parlé de Léonard
Miller donc je vais le laisser parce que
il est pas dans summer Love et
Entertainment du côté de lui
me dis pas que tu as aimé lui
donc chez le champion titre
Entertainment grand attitude de le mec
met un lay up il Flex jusqu'au bout du
banc adverse il est Pipo inzagi du
bateau il est mais il flex pour rien du
tout j'adore il a la taille il a
suffisamment de qualité athlétique il a
le shoot
il hésite pas à aller au contact
franchement je serais pas étonné que
Denver lui trouve une place dans la dans
un bout de rotin à la saison prochaine
par le Denver Nuggets quoi des champions
en titre j'aime trop son profil et son
attitude alors pas du tout un futur star
mais grossover je le regardais je me
disais demain je vais me faire le replay
zone donc vu que le nom de la section
c'est summer love je sais pas pourquoi
allez-y s'il vous plaît allez regarder
il y a des extraits de match et
et des matches évidemment en replay
ouais je sais pas c'est j'en reviens
toujours à cette histoire et si je
touche du bois un jour j'arrive à être
dans un management NBA toujours à cette
histoire de qui peut jouer un quatrième
quart de match au printemps
ce qui a des gars qui sont hyper
talentueux mais qui se font soit on est
un tel niveau en playoff que tu te fais
soit complètement ciblé en défense soit
tu contribues pas assez en attaque et je
pense qu'il peut totalement avoir sa
place dans des sacs un peu stretch où il
demande à yo kitsch la balle dans le
corner et il finit de trois drivés go by
vers le panier Entertainment j'adore et
ce qui vous a surpris vous qui était NC
et lover
Titouan et Mathias donc qui connaissait
quand même un peu sans doute Hunter
et ce qui vous a surpris dans cette
semaine en ligue alors c'est des choses
nouvelles c'est pas le joueur que j'ai
le plus vu pour être honnête cette
saison
de football
entertain zone
qui est quand même été drafté assez haut
assez de manière assez surprenante
il avait plutôt une étiquette de shooter
exclusifs spécialiste 3 points avant la
draft mais c'est vrai que pendant cette
semaine League il a monté il a montré
d'autres choses et comme type Bastien
une personnalité qui marque et qui fait
aimer qui fait aimer les fans quoi tout
simplement
absolument et
du coup ils ont grave huit vas-y et
Titouan tu voulais ajouter un truc non
non comme vous j'ai pas énormément
regardé Clemson cette année et j'ai
encore moins suivi Denver et ça
summerling donc ok c'est honnête c'est
bien
Denver qui n'a pas de rareté ils ont
beaucoup de draftés puisque ils ont ils
ont fait un trade
pour aller chercher Julian stronger
donc le shooter de Gonzaga
et ils ont aussi drafté leur choix avec
le 32 qui est déjà le Pickett que tu
aimes beaucoup Mathias non je me trompe
qui
peut qui peut pourquoi pas alors cette
plus compliqué d'avoir du temps de jeu à
ce poste là mais
parce qu'en plus ils ont guidés encore
mais en tout cas qui peut avoir qui peut
avoir sa temps de jeu il est grand enfin
il est grand il est grand pour sa
position il est un peu un peu polyvalent
c'est le profil de
Denver aime
c'est être plus dur quand même selon moi
de lui trouver une place
tu peux décrire vite fait piquette
Mathias pour pour ceux qui connaissent
pas parce que j'imagine quand même
si tu veux genre parlerai peut-être en
hautec
OLE si on fait une section ok ok pas mal
ça va être des hautes
donc qui est ton summer love à toi
bah moi mais je vois que j'avais
sélectionné on en a parlé
donc je pense que je vais partir plus
sur un autre joueur assez succinctement
il m'a fallu moins d'un match pour avoir
un nouveau coup de coeur sur scooter
Anderson
tout simplement
en tant que fan des blazer je suis
plutôt serein
même avec un un défenseur incroyable qui
amène Thomson sur le dos pendant une
bonne partie du match bah ça l'a pas
empêché de se correr et de faire son jeu
tout simplement donc voilà moi c'est mon
c'est mon coup de coeur très content
d'avoir dans mon équipe merci
parle-moi de la draft de Hornet
Sébastien je me demandais si on allait
lancer ce débat ou pas
on a pu beaucoup de temps faut le dire
très rapide dans la même lignée que
souvent moi je Twitter cette merde il y
a quasiment 10 ans vous dormez bien
quand vous avez un bon géant un bon
proprio et à mon coach
c'est la transit hein c'est même pas qui
est tout à fait à la direction c'est
même pas si Michel sera encore là donc
bon avant d'être Miller je lui souhaite
tout l'avenir du monde je souhaite que
Nick Smith qui était quand même lui
aussi un crack bien annoncé c'était quoi
pareil top 5 top 10 avant les années
arkan ça il a fait cette année
bon allez honnête il continue à
accumuler mais
je suis obligé désolé je suis obligé de
soupirer en fait parce que les
franchises où il y a pas c'est pas
linéaire il y a pas de il y a pas de
vision c'est pas ce qui se passe tu
draft sur quoi sur qui on sait pas on
sait pas on sait pas le truc c'est que
même eux ils savent pas visiblement ils
savent que comme chaque il savait pas
non plus
on sait pas si ça se trouve ils vont
garder la maïs bridges il va être devant
mon meilleur dans la Rota ils vont
garder Gordon c'est pas trop non mais en
fait la Titouan il a raison la décla de
coupe chaque les lunaires alors merci le
lendemain de la draft on a fait un
interro à la con avec Alex de réaction
et je dis tu as vu Michka en réaction
quand il pourquoi vous avez pris le truc
en deux pour moi je sais pas vous mais
la vot fr c'était ceci n'est pas ma
décision on a décidé à ma place je suis
en voyant peinture en conférence de
presse
parce qu'en plus en soi enfin Brendon
Miller c'est un très bon joueur il y en
a beaucoup qui lui sont tombés dessus à
cause de speak c'est c'est un très bon
joueur avec un très bon potentiel
j'ai reçu cupchak il arrivait avec une
explication un argument voilà pour x ou
y raison pour des questions de fit même
si personnellement je suis pas d'accord
surtout quand tu piques en trois mais
bon admettons pourquoi pas mais là ouais
c'est
le choix plus l'argument derrière c'est
après sur le reste de la drape de
Charlotte bon effectivement
c'est risqué quand même de prendre mix
Smith
même si c'est une belle opportunité
assez bas mais
en fait personne ne se marchera dessus
c'est ça qui est bien c'est super et du
coup je t'ai un peu déçu de voir moi moi
Marie Bailey atterrir là-bas café une
belle summer ligue d'ailleurs
qui a été efficace et sobre alors que
lui aussi était un prospect annoncé top
10 à un moment donné pendant ces années
High School mais qui a su s'adapter à
autre chose parce qu'il est allé dans
une fac on joue au basket on y revient à
Lucie elle est non mais bon
est-ce que est-ce que de qui on a pas ah
oui on a dit on a dit Nick Smith il joue
Arkansas avec Anthony black la draft
d'Orlando
Titouan qu'est-ce que tu as pensé de la
draft d'Orlando qui donc je te fais le
résumé si tu l'as pas en tête quand même
Anthony black Jett Howard
j'ai bien aimé Anthony black j'ai un peu
plus de réserve mais jetowart c'était
mon deuxième choix pour le meilleur feat
en fait je trouve le fit intéressant et
vous avez besoin ils ont un besoin
absolu de spaceing et tous les fans
d'Orlando voulait absolument gridy Dick
et je trouve qu'en fait jetworks c'est
pas mal parce qu'en fait tu as un
excellent shooter qui peut jouer offball
mais car en plus un petit topside
si tu lui fais quelques répétitions mal
en main alors je sais pas s'il l'aura
beaucoup avec Wagner et banquero et full
ça à côté mais ouais non tu as un joueur
qui shoote qui défend avec un peu
d'obside donc je trouvais ça intéressant
Anthony black ouais c'est un Guard un
peu des grands words comme on n'en voit
pas mal depuis quelques années
maintenant
qui est plus un ailier d'ailleurs
Bolender qu'un Guard par rapport à sa
taille
et ouais non bon défenseur mais qui a
pas de shoot donc
voilà avoir commencé ça m'énerve les
éléments de langage en interview ah qui
vous comparez à Theresa Liberty Josh
geedy machin tu peux pas être original
franchement
dis-moi qui sont tes inspirations c'est
même pas qui vous comparer parce que
dans ce cas qui sont vos inspirations je
sais pas dis-moi des trucs un peu fun
quoi Julie serving
ça m'agace
Anthony black qu'est-ce qu'on en pense
Bastien de qui c'est quoi le projet il
va jouer ou pas moi j'aime beaucoup
donc je pense que ça peut le faire la
doublette Anthony black get Howard ils
sont continués à augmenter très
sérieusement le niveau de Qi dans cette
franchise donc c'est très bien il était
pas bas mais il était déjà bien continué
à augmenter d'ailleurs Orlando était
beaucoup plus proche du pays que du
bottom de la semaine dernière donc à
surveiller très très près en landau la
semaine prochaine cam Johnson il vient
de prendre 100 patates là cet été on
souhaite la même Adji toward on se
souvient de la réaction de Kobe en
sortie de draft tous les 10 c'est mon
gars qui aime Johnson et tout le monde
était un peu en mode
on va voir bon bah voilà une vie
actuelle c'est bien donc il y a du feat
juste cette histoire de savoir combien
est-ce qu'il y aura de garde à Orlando
la semaine prochaine parce que entre
James marquait le foot koh-lantony et un
terrible qui va être plutôt en poste 1 2
apparemment
il y a un moment
il y a quelqu'un qui va avec quelqu'un
qui va jeter ou c'est moi
ben ouais tu as choisi ce X en quoi en 5
derrière ce petit
et là tu vas chercher direct alors après
il y avait pas non plus des profils
aussi hauts avec énormément de potentiel
mais mais Anthony black 6e du coup ça
veut dire que tu vas dire tu vas coup tu
vois quoi tu vas acheter les deux dans
le jardin et tu vas dire je prends le
meilleur quoi
tu les arroses pas et tu vois ça sent
bref
j'aime beaucoup potentiellement en tout
cas la longueur de
la Wagner
c'est le projet Mathias tu voulais dire
un truc Anthony black insiste trouvait
ça un peu peut-être moi j'aime bien le
joueur avec lequel je prenais plus de
plaisir à regarder cette année mais en 6
je trouve ça un peu notamment du fait de
ces limitations offensive sur son jumper
mais pour revenir à ce que tu disais
c'est vrai que ça fait beaucoup de
Gordes à Orlando maintenant on a une
équipe NBA jamais assez de manière de
ballon donc surtout Antony black qui
pourra jouer 3 et se décaler moi je suis
pas vraiment inquiet sur ce côté là de
du problème mais après jet Howard dans
la lignée des Franz Wagner un poste 3
qui s'est posé le ballon au sol encore
une fois qu'il va mettre ses trois donc
voilà
deux choix très magique et qui peut qui
peut jouer je te Word qui peut jouer un
peu offball ça moi qui m'a intéressé
dans le pic avec Orlando puisqu'il a il
a joué notamment avec
kobekin cette année qui portait un peu
le ballon donc et leur pivot là comment
il s'appelle
qui peut jouer au football tu as dit qui
doit jouer au football moi je dirais
avec le ballon il va que à droite et il
perd la balle donc ça va pas
qui qui devra de toute façon à Orlando
je vois oui ça c'est clair
en fait
on lui souhaite comme Johnson
ouais mais Ken Johnson du coup il sait
pas sur payer c'est bien c'est un
contrat américain
aujourd'hui encore une fois quatrième
carton de fin fin juin tu peux le faire
jouer
les quatre et qui va mettre des shoots
et qui peut éventuellement mettre un One
sur une position mal défendue
ma foi
c'est l'heure des
ce qu'on a ce qu'on a est-ce qu'il y a
des franchises que vous vouliez évoquer
[Musique]
moi moi ma franchise ma draft préféré
c'est celle du Thunder parce que j'adore
Kasan Wallace et je trouve qu'ils ont
ils sont parfaitement profité de
l'opportunité de le prendre et que ça va
être le style de cette draft mais ça
c'est
étonné qu'on n'ait pas eu un petit mot
qui pouvait à la fois aller dans le
meilleur feat mais aussi dans le coup de
gueule potentiel de
Rémy raquès en 18
en 18 au 8
on dit toujours ça du joueur qui tombe à
Miami en fait c'est ça c'est moi je
l'avais potentiellement dans mes coups
de gueule parce que c'est un joueur que
j'adore depuis trois quatre ans là aussi
elle est j'adore le joueur mais je
l'avais clairement pas je l'avais plus
dans mes slippers donc au second tour
que que dans ma loterie ou dans mon top
20 mais je me dis je n'ai pas finalement
je n'ai pas choisi dans mon coup de
gueule parce que je me dis jurisprudence
pas trailer
donc voilà tu voulais pas être ridicule
non mais moi je me je me pose beaucoup
de questions parce que
Mathias je pense que tu es d'accord
qu'on voyait jouer à yucie elle est on
se disait que c'était un bon joueur NCA
beaucoup de talents de polyvalence
offensive de leadership de Swagger tout
ce que tu veux
mais en fait je ne vois pas
comment il va pouvoir défendre
positivement en NBA et si et si il y
arrive ça veut dire que il faut il faut
que je revois complètement la manière
dont j'évalué prospects défensivement
nous sommes posés un problème
mais effectivement il est il se faisait
grailler par par les gars quand il était
en switch et même par des mecs pas
forcément ultra rapide quoi donc
[Musique]
je veux bien qu'il y avait alors pour ça
défense il avait pas de protecteur de
cercle derrière lui ce qui est quand
même un problème enfin la plupart du
temps en tout cas parfois il jouait il
jouait quand même un seul grand et jouer
un peu petit du ciel
donc donc ouais c'est très étonnant
comme choix Mathias toi aussi tu étais
tu étais bouche bée
était absent des moques
pendant toute l'année et puis une ou
deux semaines de la draft PAM il est mis
en 16 donc on a pas trop compris
pourquoi moi c'est un joueur que je vais
revoir forcément il y a un truc que j'ai
pas que j'ai pas suivi maintenant ce
qu'on peut pas reprocher en tout cas
avec ma caisse c'est que c'est un bon
joueur de basketball tout simplement et
le 8 c'est le 8 on peut pas aller contre
le 8 donc dis-toi aussi un bon joueur de
basketball n'a pas été il a pas été
pique
pas tant que ça en plus
[Rires]
bon allez
messieurs c'est il faut que ça s'affiche
c'est mieux
c'est bastien qui commence avec une
énorme hot take oh non les pas énorme
parce qu'elle est pas très fun
c'est un truc de geek je surveille un
petit peu je pense que pour la première
fois depuis 2003 4 avec le bras des mélo
on aura deux Rocky à minimum minimum
d'euros qui à 20 points de moyenne
la semaine prochaine c'est pas arrivé
depuis 2003
on a eu des gars qui ont été à 20 à 18 à
machin
rapides avec Evans comme on dit
je pense que il y a un truc à trouver là
dans
monsieur
voir ce qui va se passer avec scoot
Anderson dont je pense les facilités au
scoring peuvent se démontrer assez
rapidement et sur la durée de la saison
en fonction de ce qui va se passer avec
lui je pense que ce sera pas trop une
difficulté pour lui on a une tendance
d'explosion aussi offensive donc de plus
en plus de joueurs qui score plus
facilement on est plus moins sur les
range de la fin des années 2000 ou tu
mets 16 17 points c'est extraordinaire
va maintenant tu peux les mettre
et puis bah faut voir il y a toujours un
slipper qui peut tomber mais sinon je
pense que du Victor et du scout peuvent
se livrer une très très belle bataille
la saison prochaine je vois qu'on me dit
triang et dancing c'était un très beau
duel à 20 et 19 points de moyenne je
crois à peu près sur 20 ou 17 points de
moyenne sur la droite 2018 mais ça
ferait donc 20 ans qu'on a pas vu ça et
non ça peut arriver même si Damian
lillard n'est pas trader
ah non
je pense que non je pense que ça va être
pour scout et Victor c'est juste de
savoir s'il y avait un slipper ce sera
qui est le troisième parce que j'ai pas
l'impression que ce sera Brandon Miller
[Musique]
c'est qui votre troisième messieurs si
vous en avez un Bastien aussi un endroit
le problème c'est que marcaden va avoir
pas mal de ticketshoot mais quand tu
vois ce qu'il y a sur le sur les postes
de Guardi pourquoi pas
si si je vais mettre une pièce sur un
autre un troisième joueur
dans le premier tour là ouais je dirais
que de toute façon 20 points faut avoir
la baballe quand même c'est pour ça donc
c'est assez rare tu as des belles
batailles de Rocky de l'année en fait à
la base je regardais des batailles de
Rocky année parce qu'en fait j'ai sorti
sur ce truc de stats mais je pense que
Victor et scout entre autres dans ce
livret une très très belle bataille
vraiment je pense que ça va être assez
serré que ça va être ricain versus non
ricain et que ça va être un gros bordel
tout le monde doit avoir ses arguments
Mathias va arriver avec des torches on a
un meilleur bilan que les Spurs
qu'est-ce que ça rade c'est la faute
Adam silver il y aura tout il y aura
aussi de chez hongrin tout à fait qui va
débarquer donc je pense qu'on va avoir
une excellente course au Rocky de
l'année jusque statiquement ça fait très
longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu de gars à 20
points donc je pense avec le cas cette
saison
juste par rapport à Brandon Miller Alex
tu t'évoquais son nom le seul problème
je pense pour lui c'est que bah déjà tu
as la mélo qui va prendre pas mal de
possession et surtout à l'heure actuelle
à l'instant t il y a toujours Terri
Rosaire il y a toujours Gordon et World
et vu comment comment est géré elles
sont géré leur net je sais pas quelle va
être la place de Brendon Miller dans la
hiérarchie en termes de distribution de
tickets shoot en fait non mais je suis
d'accord mais je dis juste ça parce que
je vois pas
en vrai aux art Thomson si tu donnais
plein de ballons il pourrait mais
[Musique]
c'est pas le projet en tout cas du côté
du Houston
juste rapido on parlait de chat vous
avez truc à dire sur chat ça faisait un
an qu'on avait pas vu jouer quand même
en ligue mais
bon
j'espère que
j'espère que je vais pas retomber de bas
quand je vais voir ces premiers match
NBA il y a pas de raison
ou une autre optèque tiens deux des 10
meilleurs contrats de la NBA ou même de
des 5 meilleurs contrats de la NBA
seront de cette cuvée seront rouquis
je pense ouais je pense que c'est je
pense que c'est faisable Mathias taotech
apparemment tu
vois
sera le meilleur joueur du second tour
de cette draft
de l'histoire
pour Nicolas
non mais en fait c'est un joueur qui va
qui était sous les radars cette saison
et qui s'il est drafté en 32 par les
Nuggets c'est pas pour rien les Nuggets
qui derrière Jamal Murray ont pas
vraiment de meneur gestionnaire vraiment
sur lequel on peut on peut filer le
ballon et John Pickett c'est un joueur
très expérimenté très très bon playmaker
et qui maîtrise à la perfection de
piquant un rôle ça tombe bien quand un
Yoki est à côté de toi je pense vraiment
que pick-up il va avoir cinq minutes
comme tu disais il y a Coline gilespy
enfin j'ai des Spike qui peut essayer de
concurrencer sur cinq minutes mais
sikat même s'il a un jeu atypique
qui parfois pose des questions sur sa
transition en NBA peu déstabiliser des
défenses va perdre très peu de ballons
enfin distribuer et voilà il va avoir un
impact très très bon
c'est marrant déjà une piquette parce
que c'est vraiment un nom je pense qu'on
a dit il y a quatre ans dans les
premiers podcasts sur sur ce n'était pas
les premiers podcasts envergure donc
commencé à parler des gens qui sont en
seniors maintenant quoi et qu'on a suivi
tout le long à chaque fois on disait ah
il est bon mais quoi il est bon mais là
il manque un truc mais sinon il a tout
il a y compris le profil statistique
avec peu de balles perdues du playmaking
défensif beaucoup enfin plutôt pas mal
il lui manquait un peu d'adresse souvent
il manquait de l'adresse et lui manquait
de provoquer des fautes et cette année
il a fait les deux et il lui manquait
une vraie fac aussi parce qu'il a
démarré dans une fac
No Name et après il est parti à pain
state et là il a commencé à se faire un
an non pas de painstate ce soit
mais c'est dans une grosse conf
on nous a parlé allez je te laisse à
OTECH Titouan et après on parlera il y a
des noms qui sont tombés dans le chat et
qui qui reviennent ça me fait rire alors
moi je suis plus prêté au jeu j'ai
vraiment pris un truc très haute
d'Harry Whitey
va finir dans le top 5 de la course roki
de l'année
alors évidemment ça va dépendre de sa
capacité à rester en bonne santé
forcément et surtout de l'effectif des
net au lancement de la saison parce que
on a vu des rumeurs de traits autour de
lillarde et que Brooklyn pourrait servir
un peu de médiateur donc c'est possible
que l'effectif change drastiquement mais
à l'instant T si reste en bonne santé
moi je pense qu'il peut être le deuxième
ou troisième meilleur joueur des net
alors troisième parce qu'il y a klaxon
mais en termes de en termes de de volume
et d'impact évidemment un cam Johnson
par exemple est meilleur ou un torian de
finesse sont des meilleurs joueurs de
basket actuellement mais en termes de
potentiel je pense qu'il peut avoir plus
de ballons mettre plus de points
des sa saison rookie que j'ai rien fait
ouais moi j'ai vraiment beaucoup aimé ce
que ce que j'ai vu à Duke et je trouve
que
il est il fait un petit peu il fait un
petit peu Chubby comme ils disent des
Américains mais je trouve très
mobile défensivement et je le trouve
vraiment fort dans sa capacité à gérer
le jeu que ce soit pour lui ou pour les
autres et en vrai je pense que si les
net vraiment finissent par trade du
Dorian finish voilà faire un peu de
place sur les ailes je pense que il peut
avoir carte blanche en sortie de banc et
je serai pas étonné qui tourne à une
quinzaine de points par match en sortie
de banc let's go
ça c'est fort parce que quand même le
gars
c'était un badgehotmaker surtout à la
base
je parle sur le contrôle de Mathias mais
avant avant du houx que c'était un
badgehock Maker après il se blesse il
rentre dans un rôle il le fait bien à
Duke pour le coup et
dire qu'il va direct performer avec le
ballon dans sa première année ça va
c'est vraiment une hothèque mais si ça
s'avère vrai tu auras parole de Messi
j'allais pas prendre comme mot take
Victor
ouais voilà ça c'était un peu mou ça
c'était un peu mou j'avais pas trop aimé
non il y avait plein de octets possibles
sur sur le fait que Kalan soit présent
dans le podcast par exemple
j'envoie des messages non il m'a envoyé
un message il passe la douane je suis
pas trop non mais toi tu as une autre
paye ou pas ah pardon est-ce que moi
j'ai une take ah je n'ai pas préparé
alors attends
non c'est vrai map après j'ai beaucoup
de Take pour pour faire rire les gens
mais ce que j'ai des hautes ce que j'ai
des Tech pour moi
en fait pour moi Léonard Miller ça sera
un des 7 ou 8 meilleurs joueurs de cette
draft
tu vois c'est un truc et d'ailleurs il a
plutôt assez bien joué même s'il m'a un
petit peu inquiété défensivement ce
merlink je pensais qu'il avait qu'il
avait plus progressé que ça et je l'ai
trouvé moyen défensivement moyen c'est
parce que je suis gentil mais mais
Leonard Miller c'est un joueur qui fait
2 mètres 08
minima qui est délié qui peut créer pour
lui qui peut créer pour les autres qui
peut driver qui maintenant visiblement à
une gestuelle à peu près correcte alors
que vu d'ouï par il y a 18 mois c'est
juste un miracle
c'est un joueur qui n'a cessé de
progresser et qui produisait du 20 10 en
Gilly face à des adultes cette année
alors qu'il avait 18 ans
c'est pas un monstre je vois Didier qui
dit c'est le prochain Jeremy grande
c'est pas un monstre d'athlétisme comme
dira migrants c'est pas un mec qui est
qui est
qui a le muscle rapide ça n'existe pas
mais voilà qui est très vif quoi mais
par contre il y a de la puissance il y a
du contrôle corporel alors que il a
grandi très tard et ça va ça va aller en
s'améliorant et puis surtout il a du
cerveau quoi il a du cerveau il a de la
technique et moi j'achète
green en fin de carrière alors
[Musique]
ouais ouais mais plus en fait il est
plus grand il est plus carré que même un
Jeff Green je trouve je trouve qu'il
prend plus de place je pense qu'il peut
jouer pivot éventuellement
sur des petites séquences parce qu'il a
le
parce qu'il a le la vision dans les
aides etc il est pas impactant c'est pas
des règles Lively qui touchent le haut
de la planche mais
voilà maotech Miller comme qu'est-ce que
je pourrais dire
ce que top 10 des joueurs de cette draft
ça va un peu rien dire subjectif
Léonard Miller aura au moins trois NBA
faux le meilleur second joueur du second
tour ce sera le dernier
c'est vrai c'est pas possible il y a
déjà ce genre de Wolfs
Grégory Jackson junior parce que ça fait
plusieurs fois que je le vois apparaître
dans le chat et alors les gens aiment
bien
le trou noir
c'est déjà c'était le plus jeune joueur
de la draft et il avait à 18h à peine
pas lui enlever ça
à la base il devait participer à la
draft 2024 mais finalement il s'est
reclassé dans la 2023 c'était une top
recrue là encore 5 étoiles etc
il devait dans ce Carolina finalement il
a annulé il est parti assez oscarolina
pas la meilleure idée du siècle vu le
jeu niveau de jeu de South scarline et
ça a trouvé dans une équipe
horrible à regarder et puis
dans un premier temps ces qualités
sautées aux yeux et puis petit à petit
ses défauts ont pris le pas et voilà son
implication défensive le fait de se
royalement du rebond et puis
d'être comme tu dis un trou noir par
moment
on fait que ben voilà il a glissé au
second tour
mais c'est
pas de potentiel vous avez vu des matchs
de Summer League de lui là ou quoi oui
moi non oui Bastien
c'est formidable sur Youtube mais il
faut regarder les matchs complets en
fait il y a deux côtés du terrain donc
en fait en compréhension de ce qui se
passe autour incroyable offensivement tu
dis Jackson il y a pas de problème c'est
juste con c'est comme Rudy c'est quand
que le basket se joue à 5
c'est dur mais juste probablement
alors ça elle est belle je vous êtes
chiant
ils ont raison ils ont raison
à chaque fois on a des trucs sur Twitter
et tout mais non on vous adore mais tout
Manu Camara qui se voulait qu'on vous
dise il va pas jouer quoi
merci d'être venu
[Rires]
donc vous l'avez vu jouer en summerlock
mais peut-être que Mathias c'était chez
toi en plus non
tes conférences en vrai moi je serais
moins dur que toi je pense que vu le
roster en plus de de plus de joueurs
mais ça joueur européen qui sont pas
beaucoup de joueurs donc il peut avoir
des minutes
et en plus voilà tout manie c'est un
super défenseur un gros impact défensif
de l'athlète maintenant offensivement
encore une fois c'est c'est juste à
trois points qui un peu compliqué mais
qui progresse petit à petit et les vieux
mais bon pour avoir des minutes avec son
profil défensif
bon je vous laisse un peu de temps pour
réfléchir à cette question qui est le
Nasri de la cuvée donc le undravated
mais en attendant j'ai une question pour
Bastien est-ce que tu es déçu que les
requêtes c'est pris frais de vanvlit
pour le développement de la même Thomson
ah non ah non non
il y a des gens qui sont dessus
voilà
bonjour en effet aux copains du Chat du
Sénégal puisque Mohamed Gueye fait
partie des jolis potentiels à développer
et qu'il y a des gens qui nous écoutent
dans le monde entier c'est formidable
il y a juste le il y a juste le tarif
qui est un peu
qui est un peu étonnant mais
tout projet de développement qui
fonctionne passe par la présence d'un
vétéran qui sait comment une franchise
doit fonctionner et qui a gagné un titre
NBA Fred van fleet coach toutes ces
cases tu veux un bon relais coach meneur
tu l'as donc c'est formidable pour fier
ça à 20 Thompson et Java Smith Jane et
compagnie moi j'ai moi j'aime beaucoup
cette signature pour les requêtes je
sais pas vous mais moi c'est là c'est le
pilier d'un tout petit peu de
crédibilité dans le projet Rocket ce qui
n'a pas été le cas depuis quelques
années
oui mais en plus Fred Vanelli tu vas
partout franchement là c'est bien il va
leur mettre du plomb enfin il sait d'où
il vient etc c'est très bien moi aussi
je suis très content et amène Thompson
peut jouer avec Fred van Blitz
sans problème
après il y a beaucoup de garde aussi
mais c'est un autre truc alors le
undrafted messieurs
c'est dur
tout c'est dur chercher un peu toute la
liste des parce que je les ai pas tous
en tête
je me dis alors j'ai du mal à l'imaginer
dans une équipe aussi compétitive mais
je me dis si James Harden part et que
c'est vraiment le no man's land sur le
bac courte des 6h derrière taires maxi
je me dis tercavians Smith
pourrait potentiellement dans ce rôle un
peu d'énergie de bon
pourquoi pas je me dis si Colantoni ou
Jordan farceur arrive pourquoi pas
parle-nous de terre Smith donc
visiblement qui est moi je sais mais si
tu fais ces comparaisons c'est pas pas
porter sur un pass
non même si cette année pour le coup on
a vu pas mal de progrès là-dessus en
plus j'ai eu la chance pour la première
fois de ma vie et l'unique fois
d'ailleurs de le scooter en real life
contre bon c'était contre Boston College
donc
l'adversité était éliminée
mais non bon c'est un oui c'est un gros
shotmaker je dirais même un bad
shotmaker
qui est très fin trop fin d'ailleurs
très maigre et qui mais par contre qui
peut shooter qui a pas peur de la
distance qui peut shooter n'importe où
je trouve que c'est un bon driver et un
bon finisseur
après voilà en NCA prenez beaucoup de
tirs qui n'aura pas trop NBA beaucoup de
minerais-je de long minerai range
beaucoup de pull-up donc
ouais si une équipe lui donne ce rôle
d'énergie en sortie de banc avec une
petite avec carte blanche un peu pour
faire ce qu'il veut en attaque
il peut faire quelques cartons offensifs
mais s'il veut jouer dans des équipes
plus compétitives et sur le plus long
terme je pense qu'il faudra qu'il
apprenne à jouer un peu plus of ball
défensivement je trouve alors en un
contre un très limité mais il est quand
même des longs bras je trouve et sur
quelques sur quelques lectures of ball
il est pas mal dans l'interception je
trouve c'est un bon intercepteur il y a
tout n'est pas acheté défensivement
contrairement à ce qu'on peut ce qu'on
aurait tendance à croire sur ce genre de
profil de feu follet offensif
j'ai oublié de parler j'ai oublié de
parler je l'ai vu passer dans le chat
j'ai oublié parler du meilleur joueur de
la Summer League et personne n'en a
parlé je suis très déçu
Guy Santos
et ben il se développe le cochon il a
pris des épaules il a il est déçu il est
décidé sur dans tout ce qu'il fait il
est plutôt pas mal à droit moi j'aime
bien je pense qu'il va avoir une place
dans le roster des Warriors en tout cas
j'espère parce que je l'aime beaucoup je
l'aime d'amour
moi j'ai un candidat au undrafted tu en
as un Mathias
je sais plus trop de noms qui me vient
en tête de draftted mais parler vite
faire un joueur que personne connaît je
pense quoi que peut-être Bastien connaît
parce que c'était dans son équipe milse
Norris
voilà
cette info moi j'adore un grand qui
chute qui bouge très bien et qui a des
petits flashs de protection d'arceau il
était à la fac de Santa Barbara
USA
ok made Inori alors ça c'était original
on les met je sais même pas s'il a une
fiche sur notre site pour te dire comme
il était connu si je pense si je l'ai
fait c'est toi qui l'a fait
et
il y a une question aussi pour toi qui
était spécialiste de la Big tn on l'a eu
sur Twitter est-ce que les gens sont
affolés actrices Jackson Davis donc on
nous demande si c'est le style de la CUV
voilà
potentiel style donc ça va c'est pas
aussi faire que ça
non mais t'es pas obligé de dire oui tu
peux aussi dire voilà non non c'est le
profil un peu de pivot undersize qui
était très bon Annecy parce que grosse
coureur gros rebondir etc mais qui aura
assez d'imitation NBA parce que trop
petit parce que patchoul du tout il a
des armes à feu valoir parce que c'est
un bon protecteur d'arceau il a un vrai
vrai jeu de passe
voilà il a un contrat je crois parler
Warriors peut-être qu'ils croient en Lui
on verra
c'est vrai qu'il a un contrat moi
j'avais un candidat pardon je suis
vulgaire je l'ai je l'ai
je les zappe attends attends
je suis Dark et
effectivement
c'est un joueur qui jouait à Sanjo the
state
Moore il a eu un twest pour ça que je
l'ai je l'ai sélectionné
peut-être des bêtises
[Musique]
et Guillaume dans chat tu peux tu peux
inventer des noms effectivement mais
cela je existe pour de vrai
un mot peut-être un mot un geste pour
conclure ce live ou des sujets qu'on a
pas abordé qui vous tient à cœur un
homme dont on n'a pas parlé une
moi je peux conclure en très très rapide
après je te file la parole dis-toi parce
que ça va être très court très simple et
c'est un clin d'oeil
kobibround comme ils peuvent skin ça y
est toute une génération de parents a
été placée par le mamba donc un petit
hommage une pensée pour Monsieur Bryant
qui nous regarde de là-haut puisque les
premiers Kobby débarquent en NBA en fils
de donc quelque part la maman de quoi
disait que c'était notamment un peu en
rêve je crois que les deux comment ok je
crois que biberon aussi c'est un donc
très très de la fournée de Victor qu'on
aura en 2044
qu'est-ce que tu as pensé de la draft
d'Atlanta toi qui est quand même assez
proche de sa vie c'était ma pépite du
top 15 et il est tombé Atlanta j'étais
très content
donc j'aime beaucoup le joueur ce qui
est en deuxième partie de saison à
michigana d'accord
donc hâte de voir ça en développement
derrière
messieurs triang et des jeunes timmerais
et monsieur mohamedge qui vraiment un
bon qui a été fait pour la semaine
League parce que c'est vraiment le c'est
vraiment la plateforme idéale pour les
super athlètes qui a un bout de shoot en
plus enfin il a un côté flux cassé
étonnant et il y a un peu plus de place
au poste quête depuis quelques jours
donc je pense pas qu'il a un truc stable
mais
eux deux sont très clairement les deux
garçons
à surveiller puiser Griffin qui a
développé son under la semer League donc
tout va bien oui Adrienne Griffin on
l'aime bien
on l'aime bien Titouan
non je voulais je vais m'en servir de
conclusion mais j'ai juste regardé la
liste des undravted et j'ai vu qu'il y
avait un calling castelton qui avait
signé un tout ouais au Lakers Lakers
ouais bien sûr et je me dis si dans un
an les Lakers ça pètent et que il y a
plus grand monde à l'intérieur déjà que
le secteur intérieur est pas
ultra rempli avec Anthony Davis qui se
blesse quand même assez souvent je me
dis voilà donc
après il a il a déjà des gosses au
collège mais vrai
il est assez je crois qu'il a fait 5 ans
d'ailleurs je crois à la fac c'est un
super senior là mais ouais dans les
potentiels grave tête qui peuvent choper
quelques minutes
je pourrais mettre une pièce sur lui
j'avais peut-être fait un peu beaucoup
surtout unique Amara je vois que ça part
en running gag
Mathias
remercier les grizzlyse pour pour leur
draft de Tarik biberovic que tout le
monde ah oui je voulais vous demander si
vous le connaissiez par le basket là-bas
non d'ailleurs Mathias c'était avec nous
je crois en live
avec le café comme sport quand le nom
est sorti et en fait on s'est tous
regardé avec Pierre aussi pierre migoud
et on s'est regardé et tout le monde il
y a eu un blanc tout le monde attendait
que l'un de nous réagisse en se disant
moi il y en a bien qui le connaît et on
est tout ça
pique suivant
pas grand chose à dire bah ouais c'était
à l'époque on faisait le second tour
j'avais que Antoine qui fait des bisous
de l'équipe d'envergure qui était
capable de me sortir des trucs sur tous
les prospects du monde quoi y compris
des Brésiliens y compris les machins et
c'est hyper rare mais bieberovic
les anciens dont c'est le métier
maintenant ils le connaissait quand même
même si nous on n'avait pas forcément
fait les devoirs sur lui c'est vrai
qu'on a pas parlé de Malcolm Cazalon
après pour ta question Alex dans le chat
que j'affiche
comme disait Bastien tout à l'heure les
pistons souhaitent de pas y être
après il a il a signé un tout ouais donc
voilà quoi
après il a un profil qui est
en théorie en fait si s'adapte bien et
on sait qu'avec Malcolm casalon c'est
quand même la plus grande
inconnue même si là il a prouvé qu'il
pouvait aller jouer plusieurs années de
suite dans une passombre mais dans une
ligue qui est pas chez lui
en Europe de l'Est
il faut quand même s'adapter faut step
up encore un peu plus en
professionnalisme en investissement
quotidien etc c'est pas facile
donc il y a ça qui va faire la
différence mais sur le papier mal comme
Cazalon
il peut théoriquement défendre
et il est pas chiant il va pas il va pas
se prendre pour un autre il a compris en
fait ça fait plusieurs années qui se
présentent et qu'en fait il enlève son
nom il a compris que il serait pas
demain ou après-demain porteur de ballon
principal d'une des meilleures équipes
au monde donc donc ça c'est important
d'avoir intégré son rôle et la
visiblement intégré année après année
patiemment du côté du je sais pas
comment c'est s'appelle cette équipe
maintenant ça change chaque année le
caca Mozart non c'était pas ça
je sais pas quoi là Jean-Sébastien
Mozart
ouais je crois que c'est le méga mega
quelque chose
comme ça bref mal comme Cazalon mais
shoot out à lui parce que il a signé un
twei et c'est cool en fait
pour lui qui a patienté très longtemps
c'est une
c'est pas un seul mot sur les champions
de Summer League qui a gagné
la meilleure équipe les Cups de evan
#oblet
et ils avaient non c'est plus mes galets
je vois dans le chat
ils avaient aimable
porter l'équipe du futur l'équipe de
demain et demain matin
est-ce que Ismaël kamagaté évoluera un
jour en NBA et ben j'aimerais bien le
savoir mais il me semble Bastien que tu
as fait un petit shoot out Ismaël sur
sur les réseaux non
Milan et torrémécina la saison prochaine
possibilité de bien se développer se
faire un bon nom pourquoi j'ai bien aimé
entertainisen parce que j'ai regardé
Ismaël kamagaté avec les Nuggets et que
s'il y a un Keven lunerall aller
chercher en NBA dans quelques années il
est là c'est marrant dès qu'il est sur
le terrain il se passe des trucs
positifs pour son équipe j'aime beaucoup
il se met il sera jamais All-Star mais
alors quel plaisir d'avoir ça
dans son effectif mais que le premier
jour il se farcie tacofall il le pousse
comme un damné il y a pas de problème il
le bug il provoque des fautes il drive
bye moi j'adore mais on va le voir à
1000 ans d'abord c'est cool qu'il aille
à Milan c'est très très cool
et on nous parlait tout à l'heure
puisque on parle du Paris basketball
indirectement de Nadir ici ben à dire
ici non et je voudrais pas une bien
l'année prochaine mais il va viser le
terrain sans doute des récompenses
individuelles
en Betclic s'il continue sur la lancée
et sur la progression qu'il a eu ces
dernières années en tout cas
Titouan tu as des nouvelles pour Johan
bégara au Celtics là ça y est c'est la
porte ouverte toutes les questions
non bah ça sent pas bon en tout cas il
est pas sorti dans les noms potentiels
pour training Kemp après il y a pas eu
toutes les invitations encore donc c'est
possible qu'il en soit vu mais je pense
pas non et plus ça va enfin de ce qu'on
a vu cette année au Paris Basket moi
j'ai pas vu une progression
sensationnelle donc
il est encore un peu de temps mais
il faut peut-être qu'il part de chez lui
Paris c'est chez lui c'est confort il y
a ses potes il y a sa famille à machin
surtout là du coup il a signé à Nanterre
si j'ai pas de bêtises 2 ans ouais donc
c'est vrai Guillaume je vais établir le
record du dernier nom à évoquer ce soir
c'est fini
peut-être non c'est fini zéro heure 39
39 secondes je sonne la fin merci
beaucoup
Titouan et Bastien vous m'avez régalé
pour votre dispo pour vos analyses et
évidemment j'imagine plein de choses à
venir sur trash talk cet été vous n'avez
pas forcément besoin de ma pub
et le café t'aime fort qu'est-ce qui
nous prévoit cet été bon pour cet été le
café crème sport il y aura des articles
sur plein plein d'autres sports mais
nous d'un point de vue basket ça va être
un peu la pause sur mon petit article ou
deux sur sur la Coupe du Monde et après
on vient pour du scouting pour la saison
prochaine Nice et Mathias qui est en
train de faire si les championnats ou
les championnats d'Europe
U18 filles
un petit peu le FBM mais maintenant on
va regarder les les compétitions de
l'équipe de France
U18
U16 etc
c'est ça et un shoot out quand même je
parle de U18 filles en moquant mais
elles sont allées en finale et elles ont
malheureusement perdu et on les embrasse
très fort on avait fait des podcasts
l'année dernière sur cette génération
qu'on aime beaucoup
du côté d'envergure avec cléan durcius
Angloma et tout ça donc un petit shoot
out of hi on en parle pas beaucoup et on
est désolé mais on les regarde voilà
merci à tous dans le chat encore 180
c'est beaucoup nous regarder des bisous
à tout le monde Alan n'arrive pas vous
vous avez le droit de lui envoyer des
messages sur Twitter et pour lui dire tu
abuses tu abuses voilà et de vous
plaindre de la lenteur de la douane
bisous tout le monde
bisous on se capte bientôt Ciao